[Music]
hey guys welcome to scrum master full
course video by simply learn
in this video we'll cover some of the
most important concepts related to scrum
we'll talk about what exactly scrum is
the components of scrum process the role
of a scrum master the scrum methodology
how scrum meetings work how scrum and
kanban are different from one another
and finally we'll cover some important
interview questions that will help you
aco interview our instructors jeff and
chandra will help you understand the
topics with ease before we begin don't
forget to subscribe and click that bell
icon to never miss an update from us
now let's jump right in hi
welcome to scrum tutorial from simply
learn
i am cmr chandra mr a professional
consultant and coach
who is certified scrum master pmp
prince2 practitioner itl for managing
professional
devops and kobit 5.
as part of this tutorial we are going to
understand the basic understanding
requirements of scrum
the agile methodology
so let us look at the problem scenario
what was there in the absence of
adoption of agile in any given
environment
so in the given scenario there is a
problem expressed
so we have a problem our consumer
doesn't like our product we will have to
make changes immediately
so now as usual any manager would
respond
the manager says make the changes
so because it's always
the changes or anything what we deliver
is in the consumer's interest so keeping
consumers interest in mind the value it
needs to be created for customers any
changes required to be done in any of
our projects
involving that consumers and customer we
were required to do the change
so but what is the problem here to do
the change so we can't we already have
started work on last batch
the waterfall model we follow doesn't
let changes to be made midway through
the process
so is it mean the waterfall model never
allows the changes to happen
that is not true under percent
waterfall model allows us to make
changes but
it doesn't allows us to make the changes
quickly so whenever there is a change
it requires lot of effort
it requires changes in documentation it
asks for the changes in various
different implementations which has
already done which is executed already
and then a lot of efforts are involved
which is time consuming and also it
involves more cost
now how do we make the change which is
required to the customer and at the same
time we don't have any specific
additional effort which are required so
these efforts whatever is being put is
acceptable to both the parties both the
stakeholders that is
the project organization as well as the
customer so how do you make it happen
quickly as well that is very important
for us
so we should have used the agile
methodologies so meaning agile
methodology helps us to do this
so one of the
agile methodologies which we are going
to look at as part of this tutorial is
scrum so let us see how scrum is going
to help the scenario so scenario of
changes which are coming up more
frequently right
right before that let us understand what
is the meaning of agile what is the
meaning of agile what it means and why
should we adopt agile
so agile means moving faster
being flexible
responding to the changes
now agile is a set of methods and
practices that focuses on iterative
development why iterative in each
iterations
agile methodologies helps us to create a
working piece of the software product
which will help us to make quick
corrections to those software piece this
is not a whole product it is part of
that bigger product
so requirements and solutions are
obtained
thanks to self-organizing
cross-functional teams collaborating so
when we say
functional team self organizing team so
these are the teams which are seven plus
or minus two the size of the team what
i'm speaking about
who basically have various different
skills each of the team members will
have various different skills
and they complement to it i think today
the devops is speaking about this
cross-functional team owning everything
as a single team some of the
organizations has already demonstrated
their devops capabilities by having this
approach like having self-organizing and
cross-functional team having an
accountability for the entire product
the particular piece of the product
module what they have created so this
helps in improving accountability and
also ensures
better visibility of the product what is
being created and delivered
so
further let us look at the advantages of
using agile so what it gives to us how
it helps so now the organization who
follows the gel methodologies so we can
see that projects follow a predefined
schedule and have a predictable cause
so schedules are seen
but
wherever there is a change is required
wherever these directions need to be
changed in terms of making necessary
changes to adopt to the
required scenario the change scenario
agile helps us it gives that flexibility
so clients have visibility of each phase
of project so it is very essential
whosoever adopts the agile methodology
the active involvement of customer has
to be ensured so they are actively
involved so customers or clients
actively involved in the sense they know
it what is happening what they are
getting they know they are acknowledging
it by giving the feedbacks every now and
then so that there is no surprise to
them at the end which used to happen
during waterfall approaches
then greater interaction between project
team and the project
means there needs to be collaboration
agile emphasizes on having the
collaboration so scrum and specific have
something called daily uh scrum where 15
minutes meeting where entire scrum team
should come in
sit together
self-organizing team as well as all that
agile teammates to come together express
what they have completed before the last
daily scrum meeting and what is spending
why is it pending and what is that they
are going to do before the next meeting
so all these are expressed this will
help the team as well as the scrum
master as well as the product owner the
visibility into what is complete what
needs to be completed and this will help
project manager or scrum master to
provide the necessary inputs better
visibility to the customers and
stakeholders as well
product output is predictable and can
sometimes happen earlier than expected
so now initially as we know so the
visibility of anything what we do will
be very less
so now as we discuss more and more as we
brainstorm more and more the visibility
into it will become more then what would
happen in future the ability to predict
will also become easier and if this
doesn't happen only with the project
team it also happens with customers and
every stakeholders who are involved in
the
project
so next high quality development testing
and collaboration is ensured since the
project is broken down
so now each iterations each module each
piece of software which is being created
are tested regularly feedbacks are
obtained from the user as well active
involvement of user are ensured so that
they are acknowledging it
so the what customer needs are given
so it is not that i discovered something
which i did not need i i'm seeing it i
told something i'm getting something
that scenario is eliminated
then the product backlog can be refined
and reprioritized
so since we move iteration wise
depending on the change scenario
depending on the directions changes we
can keep reordering or re-prioritizing
our product backlog what needs to be
created first if i have one two three
four five item i can make it as three
four one two five
so depending on the change scenario
whenever it needs to be executed it is
bit flexible and easy to do
then teams can maximize project value
since clients can provide project
priority so as we know the visibility
also increases to the consumer as well
as all the stakeholders they will also
express
what is that value they have seen from
this and this will also help in making a
decision should we continue with this
project or should we not so better
visibility better decision making better
value realization
the needs of the customer can be focused
on increasing the value delivered so as
customer gives the feedback as that
visibility increases then a customer is
getting that value and then expressing
what is the changes what is that
additionally they may required here how
can make it better so these interactions
can happen
so customer can be focused on increasing
the value delivery so in fact i think
earlier we used to speak about time to
market today we are speaking about time
to value which means how quickly are the
consumers the users or customers
realizes the value is that benefit
realized so that's what the more and
more discussion which is happening which
requires closer collaboration with
consumers and their feedbacks their
experiences with the products or
services which are being used by them it
is very essential to understand
so then various different methodologies
what we have in agile we can speak about
scrum kanban extreme programming that is
xp
lean methodologies the crystal
so now in this video tutorial we are
actually focusing on scrum so let us
understand what is this scrum is all
about
right
so before we go and understand what is
the scrum itself so let us look at the
history of scrum where it started how it
started
so right down the line during 1986 the
name scrum is first introduced by the
management experts
yukujiro nanaka and hirotakat kuchi
so japanese
so now this terminology introduced but
later in 1995
jeff suderland and ken shubert
creates the early version of what would
become the agile methodologies
so now earlier 1995 so need for agile
was sensed and it was spoken about i
mean why do we need a gel methodologies
in future what would be the future
organization which would look like so
that would trigger in terms of what kind
of approaches we may require to have
so
further 2001 the agile alliance is
founded
and first look on scrum the agile
software development with scrum is
published
so then further down the line 2002 the
scrum alliance is founded by weber and
certifications are added
then later 2006 the scrum link is
created the certified scrum courses are
taught
so people started getting certified on
scrum
then later 2009 scrum dot org is created
which offers the professionals scrum
series of certifications
then 2010 the first scrum guide is
published so which made available to
everyone so from then i think the more
and more people start adopting scrum
methodologies now interesting part is
the journey started from 1980s till 2010
various changes which has happened to
this particular methodology but one
thing we should keep in mind is
same 20 years back or 15 20 years back
if we go
the need for agile was not seen so it
was spoken but need for a gel was not
spoken much but today we're speaking
about it more and more the reason is i
think the change in the market condition
the increase in the competition
the need of responding to the change
which is asked by the consumers or the
market variations has become more and
more important for organizations and
service providers if they don't respond
to the change they may lose out in the
competition so their survival is at
stake so it is very essential for them
to understand this dynamics and respond
to those scenarios quickly so that's
where the adoption of agile the benefit
of adopting a jail were realized and
scrum become popular
so what is scrum
so let us look at that so now scrum is a
framework that enables
teams to work together
means collaboration is very important
while we become agile
so with scrum team one can
look i mean see and experience so
learning from experiences happens so
those are captured
self-organized working on problems so
they work together they discuss
brainstorm
reflect on their victories means
any achievements has to be celebrated
acknowledged quick queens
recognized and their losses to improve
so wherever the things doesn't go good
necessary corrections has to be done i
think scrum approach would help in terms
of doing it quicker better
then some of the benefits using scrum
would look like steam can provide
project deliverables and in an efficient
manner
so in time
we are completing all the features and
functionality so the entire model the
methodology what is there which helps in
accomplishing those
then further time and money are used
efficiently
so
time is very important giving results in
the mentioned schedule is very important
ensuring results are coming up
effectively is important efficiently the
performance of that products
now since we are creating those small
piece
working piece in every iterations
so that experience of using that would
also be there and quick feedbacks will
come back
so that time and money is saved
and we are doing in time
so projects are divided into
smaller units called sprint so the
iterations what are speaking about the
quick iterations of activities which
happens during the adoption of scrum
when organization adopt this methodology
so it is called a sprint it's a time box
iterations which will have a set of
subset of product backlog taken as a
sprint backlog and those users stories
and epics are delivered as part of that
sprint and then those are reviewed on a
daily basis as part of daily scrum
meeting and also
we have other meetings which will happen
when we go and look at
methodology how this happens i think
we'll get better visibility
work best for fast moving projects
now whenever we need to respond quickly
whenever we want to move faster now
remember when we say moving faster means
it doesn't mean that we can allow any
defects to happen we can ignore
something we cannot do that we need to
ensure everything is taken care at the
same time all those results what are
created has to be acknowledged
right confirmed yes it is defect free so
all those which is supposed to be
addressed are taken care and things are
moving faster and better and the results
are according to
what was actually expressed as a
requirement it is fulfilling those
then scrum meetings provide the team
great visibility
since there is a daily scrum meeting
which keeps happening people speaks
about what they have done from the
previous daily scam what is that they
have accepted they will complete and
what is complete is everything is
complete or something is pending if it
is pending why is that pending and what
is that you are going to do further
before the next daily scrum meeting
so these are discussed understood so
that there's a quick 15 minutes meeting
which gives the insight and further
wherever there is a dependency
deviations which occurs
further maybe scrum master sit with them
separately to understand that in detail
so daily scrum meetings give the quick
insights
so that it increases the visibility what
is happening on ground
constantly involves feedback from
clients and customers as i mentioned
earlier while discussing about agile
active involvement of a customer is very
essential so customers should give the
feedbacks whenever that working piece of
the application or a product is given so
only then whether the product or that
module what is created is having that
features and functionality which helps
in providing necessary requirement
fulfillment is that happening or not
then making changes based on feedback
are very easy because everyone is
informed and they are aware of what is
being changed and what needs to be
changed
then individual efforts of the team
members are given focus
yes individual efforts is essential
at the same time each team member cross
skills we call it a self-organizing team
as i was mentioning earlier so each team
member will have a different different
skills different different capabilities
and also cross killing within the team
is encouraged so that the ownership on
individuals
deliverables and team as a whole working
together to deliver some features
functionality can also be accomplished
right
then scrum team involves product owner
scrum master and then scrum team so each
of these are different roles having
their own objectives to accomplish with
the specific directions
and each of this cannot be merged like
for example
the roles and responsibilities of
product owner cannot be given to single
individual who is a scrum master so both
the roles cannot be given a single
individual because it conflicts the
objectives of both the rules
so thinking about putting this one of
the team member becoming scrum master
product owner thinking in that angle is
also something which is which will not
work which will not give the required
results so now what are these roles what
are the responsibilities where is the
focus of each of the roles
so let us discuss on that now when it
comes to product owner so the product
owner is primarily responsible for
maximizing the roi by determining the
product features
prioritizing it into a list what needs
to be focused on for the next print and
constantly reprioritizing and refining
it
so the key points what we need to see
here is
so one is determining the product
features
maximizing the roi the second one
and then re-prioritizing and refining
the product backlog
now why is that needs to be done so
maximizing roi in the sense obviously
product owner should closely work with
the business and
have an insight towards what is that
business required what is that customer
require how it helps customer to
accomplish that
result so that it helps the justifying
that investment what they're doing with
the products features and
functionalities
then
speaking about reprioritizing and
refining it it depends on what features
needs to be delivered in what order so
there is already an order which is
defined
so
based on the change scenario you can
reorder it and product owner has that
ownership and responsibility so
the entire focus is on ensuring the
right product backlog prioritizing it
and also adding that user stories and
effects into
product backlog
depending on what makes sense to the
business
so the scrum master the next role helps
teams learn and apply scrum to obtain
business value
means
scrum master closely works with the team
so he or she helps remove impediments
what is impediments
something which stops
to move forward something which doesn't
allow
to deliver things the way it is required
something which stops
right so that needs to be eliminated
that needs to be understood what are the
impediments so when we say impediments
what are the impediments we can think of
the skills and capabilities of the team
that is one thing maybe the testing
environment may be a process
so anything comes as a bottleneck or
impediments which stops things to move
smoothly forward
so scrum master should work on it
identify that and support team or guide
team to
overcome those
so protects them from interfaces that
helps the team to adopt agile practices
so encouraging team to adopt agile
practices and ensuring they demonstrate
it and provides the required value as
its move forwards so since scrum master
focuses one side in terms of making
scrum team to work whereas product owner
is looking at the entire product backlog
and working more closely with the
business so they need to have a good
handshake to ensure things go well but
these two roles cannot be merged because
since it has a two different angles and
two different dynamics so
spending time accomplishing both the
things may become very challenging and
conflicting
and the prioritizing will also be
difficult
then scrum team is a collection of all
the individuals who work together to
deliver the requirements of the
stakeholders so self-organizing team
what i was mentioning what we were
discussing earlier
so these teams comes together each of
the team member will have various
different capabilities
so they contribute at the individual
level and as a team has a whole
complement or contribute towards
ultimate output and outcome and value
what they need to create
and this team should have a clear
understanding about the deliverable what
is being done
so is that deliverable what features and
functionality what they're thinking is
that going to create that value
ultimately what is need to be achieved
the requirements fulfillment which is
which needs to be happen to the
customers so they need to have that
understanding the direction should be
clear to the team
so there are certain artifacts to look
at when it comes to scrum so let us look
at that
so now we speak about the artifacts
which are the components of this crumb
process
that can improve transparency and
understanding of the work so there are
three artifacts mainly which we call it
as a product backlog
sprint backlog
then product increment so let us see
what is this one by one
so when i say product backlog so it
consists of list of new features
changes to be made to existing features
the bug fixes
changes to the infrastructure and
several other activities that the team
needs to deliver to ensure a particular
outcome so this list show product
backlogs becomes with
required features and functionalities
what needs to be delivered so
the prioritization of this has to happen
in what order what needs to be delivered
so
the product backlog is the full list
which needs to be delivered as part of
this project and as the project
progresses
a lot of new backlog item would be added
to the product backlog
as the dynamics of the particular
scenarios keeps changing so keeps adding
reprioritizing additional items to the
backlogs are added depending on what are
those dynamics
so further looking at a sprint backlog
so
sprint refers to that short period of
iterations right so which team aims to
get a given amount of work done so it
helps teams deliver working software in
a frequent manner
so sprint could be between one to four
weeks long depending on
what is that deliverable is
so sprint backlog is a subset of product
backlogs so that prioritized item what
is taken into sprint which is a time
boxed iterations
the sprint backlog contains the task the
team aims to complete to satisfy the
sprint goal so what is that sprint goal
so each of those iterations the time box
iterations will have a specific
objective to accomplish
so the sprint goal is the objective
decided for the sprint as an outcome of
negotiation between the product owner
and the team so what can be delivered
how long it takes to deliver so when it
has to be delivered the target may be
given by product owner but is it
possible feasible to complete it
there is some negotiation which happens
there
so they decide they agree yes we can do
it we cannot do it if at all we can do
it what is that it takes in terms of
effort time and cost everything is
decided discussed
so that objective of that particular
iterations is agreed upon
so once it is agreed i think team should
first identify the tasks from the
product backlog that need to be
delivered to achieve the goal
so these stars are then added to spread
backlog so there should be an agreement
between both
and once it is added once it is agreed
as part of that print
the deliverable the output of the sprint
would be
the one which needs to be completed as
part of it the objective is the goal the
results it's a specific working software
then product increment
so this refers to the combination of all
product backlog tasks completed in the
sprint and the value of the increment of
previous sprints
now when we speak about lean lean speaks
about elimination of waste it speaks
about value streams
now in each of these prints as we have a
working software being delivered
now each of these piece should keep
complementing to the what is the one
which is already delivered and what is
being delivered in future
so keeping that in mind every
deliverable will be implemented or
configured in such a way
that there is no specific bottlenecks
there is no specific constraints which
arises so this needs to be kept in mind
which requires the entire visibility
into what is that ultimate objective we
are going to accomplish so in this
product increment all those combination
of the product backlogs task which is
being done should keep this in mind team
should be very clear about it so i in
the first sprint i delivered something
in the sprint two i delivered something
but i cannot integrate them they cannot
work together
it will lead into the further issues and
then complications that should not
happen
so when we say agile it's about moving
faster fine so responding to change fine
but that should not lead towards further
complexity it should make things
simpler smoother so scrum is stressing
on that part
so an increment refers to
inspectable usable work done at the end
of the sprint it represents a step
towards overall goal or vision of the
project as i was mentioning
then the outcome should be in usable
condition even if the product owner
doesn't decide to release it
so it should be in usable condition so
two things we speak about so one is uh
release other one is deployment
now people usually get confused between
release and deployment so release about
this part what we're speaking about
product is usable
so it is released product is usable but
only after deployment user will have an
access to use it
so that is the difference release makes
a product usable whereas deployment
makes it available to the user to use so
this difference people should know so
release doesn't mean that it is already
available for user to use
so this understanding of the difference
should also be there so that
one can understand what it means by
release as well and what it means by
deployment that's why when we speak
about devops we keep speaking about ci
cd in ci cd we speak about continuous
integration
continuous
delivery and continuous deployment so in
continuous delivery speaking about
release basically so once it is released
it becomes usable so once it is deployed
it is available for user to use
and that's about the scrum artifacts
now let us look at scrum framework how
that scrum framework looks like in
entirety so what are the components
comes into picture already we spoke
about the scrum approach itself what it
is
now we spoke about understanding
artifacts then we spoke about roles in
scrum the activities for each of the
roles we understood
now where do we see all of this when we
look at a scrum framework so that
picture let us see
so when we say scrum framework already
we spoke about the product backlog
we can see that it is in the left side
in the beginning
we have a sprint planning so we spoke
about sprint the time box iterations and
from the product backlog
the items which is moving towards sprint
to a specific sprint what needs to be
delivered which become
sprint backlog
now the backlog items are taken and
scrum team work on it and does this
daily scrum meeting and once the
deliverables of that particular sprint
happens then there is a review on it
then the increment is delivered and at
the same time that retrospective what
was planned versus what is delivered
that is checked if you look at from
sprint review so you have a
retrospective to check
what is planned versus what is being
delivered at the same time the review
points will come and get updated to
product backlog as well to the product
owner so product owner should be aware
what is delivered what is pending to be
delivered and that increment is further
delivered so these increments what is
delivered to production what is deployed
in the production should have
values
that integration which happens
both all the increments coming together
to provide that
fulfillment of the requirement as well
as
creating that value what is required
so product backlog is the first step of
scrum framework is a set of list of
tasks to have successfully achieved the
goals of the stakeholders we discuss
that while discussing on product backlog
so further sprint planning happens where
the team determines the tasks from the
product catalog
they will work on and aim to deliver
during the sprint now this is negotiated
understood agreed and then most towards
spring to get delivered
then sprint backlog are the tasks
discussed during the sprint planning
means
the previous step
and also do the script planning and then
add it to the sprint backlog once it
goes to the sprint backlog as part of
the time box iteration sprint the
deliverables should happen
now scrum team the scrum team which is
actually self-organizing team as we
mentioned maybe five to ten nine members
of team
working on the task in the sprint
backlog and they will also have a daily
scrums where the team also discusses for
15 minutes
on the events where the team member
synchronizes activities and plan what
they aim to achieve in next 24 hours
what is accomplished against what is
discussed in previous daily scrum
and then
if at all any further discussions need
to be done in the correction of those
that can be taken as a separate meeting
not as part of the daily scrum so
generally daily scrum meeting would be
15 minutes it should not go more than
that it's an indicative time so quicker
updates to understand what is happening
then the sprint review happens
where once the sprint is complete so
sprint review happens which involves the
team the scrum master and product owner
and stakeholders to understand what is
being agreed upon and what is being
delivered or reviewed is that fulfilled
in the entirety that is discussed
and then during this meeting the team
shows what they accomplish during the
sprint it allows time to ask questions
make observations
give feedback and provide
suggestions right
then the product owner also presents the
product backlogs talk to the
stakeholders
to get feedback for upcoming sprints and
about things related to the backlog
now this one sprint is complete for the
next print what should be the
prioritization
so the product owner has to speak with
the stakeholders so that there is a good
understanding good handshake that what
needs to be delivered and what is the
priority in the given list
then sprint retrospective happens
so after this print review
sprint retrospective happens so during
this meeting what went well
like past mistakes potential issues
what are the new ways to handle them
which are required to be done correctly
in the next
iterations or next prints needs to be
identified
data from found from here are
incorporated when planning the new
sprint so it works like a lessons
learned what went well what did not go
well what is that we did for those what
did not go well so what is that learning
we have in these iterations so how can
we ensure that in the upcoming
iterations the same mistakes are will
not repeat
so those can be
discussed documented and then consider
while moving to the next spring
then the increment is a workable output
which is given to the stakeholders so
this is where the user actually sees the
workable piece working item and then
they give necessary feedback as well on
the particular
application piece or software piece
then there is something called scrum
board which is used during this flow of
scrum
right from product backlag to the
creation of that increment
so let us look at what is a scrum board
which is used during the scrum practice
so scrum board is a physical or virtual
tool that helps team to visualize items
in the sprint backlog so it helps in
tracking what is being delivered what is
in progress and what needs to be
delivered further
so it shows all action items during the
daily scrum helping keeping the team
focused on tasks that need to be
completion and the priorities of those
the scrum board is usually present in a
place that's accessible to all team
members it is a visual board right and
can be physical white board and stickers
or virtual software tools which can be
used and displayed on the
screen so the scrum board is divided
into different slots like to do
in progress and done
so when new sprints are started the
existing board is reset and new scrum
board is created
so since it is visual system i think it
is taking the thought from kanban
so visual system always works effective
because
the moment i know i see something is
put
against my name that i need to complete
this it's quite obvious to me that i
will put efforts to complete it so it's
a conscious effort what i will put it
works on my consciousness so something
which is not visible to me it is that
out of sight is out of mind so i will
not work on it so i may there is a
tendency to forget
let's talk about what agile is
agile is a very popular principle that
is used in software or project
management
the approach involves creating products
in an incremental manner from the start
of the project rather than delivering
all of it at once at the end of the
project
agile processes focus on frequent
inspection and adoption
on encouraging teamwork
self-organization
accountability and delivering high
quality software
the business approach is to align
development with the needs of the
customer and that of the organization
now like i mentioned earlier the agile
process delivers work in small usable
increments
for organizations to take advantage of
agile principles
they need to adhere to the values that
are mentioned in the agile manifesto
agile puts individuals and interactions
over process and tools
working products are more important than
comprehensive documentation
customer collaboration is much more
important than contract negotiation and
responding to changes cause more
significance over following a plan
with agile the clients in the project
team can have large amounts of
interaction this helps them understand
each other better
clients have greater transparency to
every phase of the project
the output is delivered in a predictable
manner and sometimes can happen sooner
than expected
it provides high quality development
testing and collaboration due to the
project being broken down into smaller
units
and thanks to continuous evaluation of
requirements plans and results
teams can respond to change really fast
now let's talk about some agile
methodologies
let's have a look at each of them
first off xp
extreme programming or xp is a framework
with which teams can create high quality
software
it can also greatly help improve their
quality of life
it also involves the appropriate
engineering practices to enable software
development now it is applicable for
teams handling changing requirements
while working with smaller teams
handling risks due to new technologies
and much more
next up we have kanban
kanban is a visual system that can help
organizations visualize their workflow
to design
manage and to improve the flow of the
systems
now it's applicable in scenarios where
the work is unpredictable
it is also used for deploying work
quickly without having to wait for the
other components
next up we have lead
lean provides a set of tools and
services that focuses on identifying and
removing waste so that the speed of the
process development can be improved
with lean waste is minimized and value
to the customer is maximized
the principles of lean can be applied to
any sector which is liable to produce
waste
then we have scrum
so we'll be taking a look at scrum in a
little bit but basically scrum is a
framework that involves teams
establishing a hypothesis
then trying it out reflecting on their
experience and making corresponding
adjustments
and finally we have crystal
crystal is a software development
approach that puts people and
interactions over tools and
processes with crystal processes are
streamlined and optimization is improved
crystal is applicable in scenarios where
the focus is on the team communication
being strengthened
for more on agile you can check out our
video what is agile
now let's have a look at what scrum is
scrum is a framework through which teams
can work together with the help of
sprints
sprints are events that are time boxed
and are usually of two to four weeks
length
scrum enables teams to learn from their
experiences
self-organize and work on their problems
reflect on their successes and losses
for improvement
the team's progress is measured with the
help of a 15-minute long daily meeting
called daily scrum
during this meeting team members talk
about what they plan to do on that day
what they did the previous day and what
roadblocks they were facing
with scrum teams can deliver their
projects in an efficient manner time and
money are used effectively
thanks to scrum meetings visibility is
improved and improvements can be made
thanks to constant feedback from clients
and customers and so much more
now let's have a look at how scrum works
so here's the entire process
let's have a look at each component
firstly we have product backlog
first a list of all the tasks that need
to be completed is created
now this list is called the product
backlog
now completion of all these tasks
represent the successful completion of
the project
next we have sprint planning
here the team decides the different
tasks that they are going to work on
and focus on delivering them
during the upcoming sprint
then we have sprint backlog now the
tasks that were discussed in the product
backlog are then added to this print
backlog which is basically just another
smaller list which consists of selected
items from the product backlog
next up we have the scrum team
the scrum team is a collection of five
to nine people who are working on the
tasks mentioned in the sprint backlog
then we have the daily scrum
now this is a 15 minute long session
during which team members can
synchronize their activities
and determine what they did the previous
day what they plan to do on that day
and what roadblocks they were facing
next up sprint review
now after a sprint is complete a meeting
involving the scrum team scrum master
product owner and stakeholders take
place
during this meeting the team shows off
what they accomplished during the sprint
questions are asked observations are
made
feedback and suggestions are also
provided
now back to the product backlog
now the product backlog is presented to
the stakeholders
so that the product owner can get some
feedback for upcoming sprints
then there's also the sprint
retrospective
now during this meeting previous
mistakes are identified
and new ways to handle them are
determined
the data that's obtained from this
meeting is also used while planning the
news trend
and finally we have increment
now in this stage a workable output is
provided to the stakeholders
and after this another sprint starts and
the whole process is repeated again
now let's talk about strum versus agile
firstly let's have a look at
methodologies
now agile is a set of principles that
are iterative and incremental
agile has a number of different
methodologies you can choose from
there's xp crystal kanban even scrum for
that matter
let's talk about strum now
scrum is an implementation of the
concepts of agile
so basically most of the important
components of agile can be applied to
scrum as well
it provides the customer with
incremental builds that are delivered to
the customer in the span of two to four
weeks
an organization can be agile but not
practice crowd
however an organization cannot practice
scrum without being agile
next up let's have a look at projects
agile is more suited towards projects
that have a small development team that
consists of experts
whereas on the side of scrum it's
usually better suited for projects that
are subject to a large amount of change
and that will rapidly
next we have leadership
now for agile a project head takes care
of all the tasks and has a very
important role to play in the process of
a job
a project head represents the entire
team and is responsible for getting
issues resolved by assigning them to the
appropriate members of the team
in scrum there's no leader
there's a scrum master who can overall
guide the sprint process but the team
addresses issues by themselves
it usually involves cross-functional and
self-organizing teams
next up we have flexibility
agile is relatively more rigid than
scrum and cannot handle changes with
these
it also requires a lot of upfront
development process and changes within
the organization
with scrum you can enable team delivery
agile requires frequent deliveries so
that they can get feedback from the end
user
this in turn will help make the product
better
the product is delivered as well as
updated on a regular basis
with scrum after a sprint feedback from
the client for a build is provided to
the team
scrum involves daily scrum meetings to
review and get feedback to determine the
next steps of the project
the next print is only planned by the
team after the current sprint is
complete
next we have collaboration
with agile collaboration involves
face-to-face interactions with team
members of other cross-functional teams
for scrum daily stand-up meetings take
place with specific roles like scrum
master product owner and the scrum team
and finally we have design
with agile the design as well as its
execution it's relatively simple
with scrum the design and its execution
can be innovative and experimental
so you might be wondering
which one should you choose
now among both these options there's one
thing that will remain common
agile
now what you can decide upon is which
agile methodology you will be choosing
is it lean is it canva or is it scrum
now if you do want to know more about
how scrum and kanban are different from
one another you can check out our video
scrum versus canva
first slide here has to do with user
stories and epics
and what i want to do team is i want to
before we get into
the user stories i want to go to the
whiteboard
and i want to just give you a little bit
more information
that might help us in organizing our
discussion that we're about to embark on
here
so a word that is not
in our slides is themes
themes are epics
and user stories
grouped together
you know similar epics and user stories
grouped together for planning purposes
so an epic is big
you would never do an epic in or pardon
me a theme in a sprint it's too big
so it's used for planning purposes
below that i would put epics
epics are
low priority
large
user stories
meaning that an epic will eventually
have to be disaggregated into multiple
user stories
the reason it would be low priority is
because if it if an epic was higher up
on the product backlog
it would have to be more detailed that's
when you would break it down so epics
are usually going to live at the lower
uh priority levels of a product backlog
and as user stories are completed and
the epic rises in priority it will
eventually be broken down into
more manageable user stories so great
big low priority user stories
then we have user stories themselves
user stories
are
functions
or features
that the product owner wants to have
developed a user story turns into
working software
that provides value to the customer
and
and
the product owner is the customer voice
the product the owner is the one who
would accept or reject completed user
stories
and then
there are tasks
and a reminder when we were talking
about the sprint planning meeting we
said the sprint planning meeting
is
got two parts to it the first part is
selecting all of the user stories that
are going to be included in the sprint
and then
disaggregating each of those user
stories into tasks
that's done in the sprint planning
meeting and then those tasks are the
things that are actually then done
when the work of the sprint begins
user stories can be estimated in story
points
or ideal days
most teams favor story points they might
start with ideal days but they will then
usually end up going to story points
tasks are
estimated in i
ideal time
which is usually hours
okay so now back to our slides
so at the top left
a use case
could be an example of a user story
so it's something that
the user wants to do and how the system
should support it
like
a use case could be
select and pay for items in a catalog
now that could actually be
an epic
or maybe a theme because maybe it would
get disaggregated into
log on screen
catalog
shopping cart and checkout
but so the use case could either be a
standalone user story or it could
actually be
a number of user stories
that would result from it
below that requirement it could be a
functional requirement a technical task
or even a bug fix
so i'm going to go back to the
whiteboard and a product backlog
is going to have a lot of user stories
that come from the customer
right whatever the customer wants them
but the team may know that it has to do
some development work in order for the
user stories to even be able to work you
know there's some system level
non-functional requirements that need to
be done
and so there could be
tech user stories
and then
can you see this low
i can't see your chats but then there
could also be defect user stories
there could even be risk user stories
now what could happen is that
the
product owner
ranks these
in priority so this one first and that
one and that one and the team says well
the only thing is is that
we have to do some development work
before we can actually do user story 2
and so what we really need to do is
insert
that
before
the
the second priority user story
and so the
priority of the user stories in the
product backlog
while it might start with just being you
know simple functional user stories
coming from the
uh product owner it will evolve until it
includes some other things that are also
considerations when it comes to
priorities because of you know successor
predecessor relationships dependencies
and things like that are um
considerations
a user story be uh back to the screen
um
bottom left now the user story
can use a fictitious user or a persona
to help
the team or the the team and the product
owner to get an idea of okay who's going
to be doing this function
uh what are they going to need in order
to be able to complete the function etc
so you try and
come up with
an actual well a fictitious but a person
who's actually doing it to kind of get
out of the realm of you know listing
requirements and you know specs and
things like that and say okay what's the
user experience need to look like
top right template a portion of a user
story
is um let me back up so a user story
card
is usually going to contain
a
brief description of the user story
using some kind of a meta language
format like we're suggesting right here
as a
user or persona i want this feature so
that i can
so not unlike our um
estimating session here
as a frequent traveler i want to eat
grapes so i can be healthier
in the one that we didn't do uh the
inventory system as a customer
okay there's a
a user
i want to get cash back so i don't have
to wait in line at the bank
okay
here's another user story as a
consumer
i want the shopping cart functionality
to easily purchase items online and
maybe that could be customer as well
um as an executive right as a suit
i want to generate a sales report so i
know which departments need to improve
their productivity
as a buyer so you can see i tried to
come up with these different roles right
here executive
sales rep etc
and that's the format as a type of user
i want some kind of goal
or feature and uh so that's some kind of
a reason
um the below that connect
connect the dots by writing all of the
user stories necessary to uncover
the entire use case so like we were
talking about right here if you want to
be able to purchase items online from a
catalog that might be
a
multiple user stories in order to
support that use case and so of course
we would want to be able to connect the
dots and see where all the user stories
fit in into the overall goal of the
project or release
and the stories um
excuse me
are grouped
to form an epic or
higher level story so epic or theme
stories can then be split into child
stories or tasks and so that's what we
were covering before right you so you
have
themes
up at the top that's the biggest
grouping if you will used primarily for
you know high level planning purposes so
you have your themes then you have your
epics which are large user stories
low priority and they're going to have
to be broken down into
smaller user stories like in the
question that we had at the end of the
the last section where
the product owner needed something done
and the team said well based on the size
of this user story it's going to take
three sprints to do
well a user story has to be small enough
to be completed within a single sprint
so a sprint can contain more than one
user story but a user story cannot stand
sprints
so that feature or function that was in
the question was probably more like an
epic it was something that would need to
be
disaggregated into
smaller user stories or perhaps it was
more of a use case that would need more
than one user story in order to actually
deliver the overall use case
let's see as a product supervisor i want
to see an unfinished part list
at
the end of the day so that i can
reallocate work the next day
great user story description
well done viraj
um did you hear that team as a product
supervisor i want to see an unfinished
part list at the end of day so i can
reallocate work the next day that is a
well-crafted description of a user story
now
here are some things that i want you to
memorize you were hoping i was done with
the memorization part
so i want you to
remember that we have to invest in our
user stories
and i was going over to the white board
and i didn't change cameras so let me do
that
i recommend um
you know figuring out how you memorize
best
so that you can if
um
well not if you wanted to what i
recommend is being able to
write out all of this stuff on plain
white scrap paper in about 14 minutes
because that's the amount of free time
you have in the tutorial when you're at
the
or when you're taking the test
eggs in does a little bit different you
maybe won't have a tutorial the only
time you'd have a tutorial is if you
were at a center taking a test
exam has other options like you can do a
paper-based test
where you get a third party you know a
buddy or somebody who will agree to sort
of proctor the test for you and they
have software that watches you while
you're taking the test and they require
you to take the laptop and do like a 360
so that um they can verify that you
don't have any cheat sheets up on the
wall or anything like that
but the point is is
you got to have this memorized
whether you're going to dump it out on
the paper or not
when i took the test
um i actually did the paper-based option
um and that was because of some kind
time constraints and it was the quickest
way to get me into the test and so i
didn't write out
any of the stuff i'd memorized but i had
it memorized and i had it memorized well
enough that i could kind of recall it in
my mind's eye
okay so
we're talking about user stories and you
have to invest in your user stories you
know i like memorizing things by
creating these charts
that have the first letter
of the word or phrase that you're
memorizing in a separate column and then
i make up a story you know that uh
um reminds me that i've got to have inv
esp this one is pretty easy probably
just invest works
um
but so let's go over that i stands for
independent
independent meaning that each user story
stands on its own
you don't
have
when we're doing scrum you don't do a
user story that won't result in working
software
we just talked about the description of
user stories right so it's a user that
needs some kind of functionality for
some kind of a reason and they're all
independent will they work together of
course they'll work together if that's
the necessity but um if you developed a
log on screen you could demonstrate
working software for the login screen
there might be another user story that
is
um you know has to do with displaying
uh the catalog and being able to flag or
select items that you want to purchase
but there'd be working software for that
would they work together yes but each
user story would complete
um or result in some kind of working
software and they have to be independent
negotiable
negotiable in the way the user story is
going to be implemented
the product owner doesn't dictate to the
team the team doesn't say it it's only
this way and we don't want to hear
anything from you
so there are discussions about the size
and implementation for each user's user
story so the product owner can't make it
so detailed
that there's no room for discussion and
the possibility of
you know the team coming up with
solutions other than what the product
owner was attempting to dictate
v
stands for valuable
meaning each user story has to create
value for the customer or the end user
e
has to be estimable
as an estimatable except estimatable is
not really a word it's estimable
um
and s is for small
has to be small enough to be done in a
single sprint if we're doing two week
sprints it has to be able to be done in
two weeks or less if we're doing four
weeks sprints it could be a larger user
story but it would still
have to be done in four weeks or less
and then the last one the t is testable
every user story needs to be testable
and it needs to be testable at two
levels remember our triangle needs to be
testable at the intrinsic quality level
unit tests etc and also testable at the
extrinsic level which is the customer
point of view which is acceptance
so every user story uh has to be
testable
okay so that's invest and so let's add
that to
our list of things to memorize
invest
and then the next one we have here is um
the three keys of a user story
so the first c team is card
so user stories
should be able to be written on a four
by six inch index card or some
media similar to that
card
the the second c
is conversation
the user story card is the item that is
used
for
the team
and the product owner
to talk and discuss in order to make
sure that
the product owner and the team are on
the same page when it comes to what is
actually supposed to be
developed
and
what you know so what it's supposed to
look like at the end
which leads us to the third one which is
confirmation
each user story
essentially has to have acceptance tests
um in it itself so
card 4x6 conversation that's the
starting point that's where uh the team
and the product owner discuss and then
eventually there will be acceptance
tests included on the user story card
in order to be used during the sprint
review to
assure that it's acceptable that there's
confirmation
okay so oh let's add that to the
memorization list
so
three c's
all right now i've got an example here
of a user story
card so we're looking right here
and if you were to go out on the
internet and search
user story cards
they would be similar there would be
some differences of course
but typically what you're going to have
is you're going to have a title or a
name for the user story and then there's
going to be some kind of unique
identifier like user story 321 then
there will be the description like we
just talked about
as a librarian i want to have the
facility of searching a book by
different criteria so that i will save
time while serving a customer
then there might be some other
descriptive words or links to other
information that might be necessary and
then there would be acceptance criteria
or tests sometimes these get included on
the back of the card but the point is is
that they are on the court on the card
rather
then there will be an estimate of size
it could be ideal days or story points
as i mentioned most teams do story
points that's more likely what you'll be
tested on as opposed to
ideal days but you know we'll cover both
so you understand
uh the differences
um there is probably it's not listed
here but there's probably going to be
a
value point assignment this is where the
product owner um
kind of determines in a relative way
the uh value of the stories just like we
were doing in planning poker the product
owner might say well this story is twice
as valuable as
this other one comparing them together
and this is what um these value points
are what's used to
prioritize the user stories that's
supposed to be a v as in value points
and then typically there's also going to
be a indication sometimes it's just by
colors um it could be words uh that has
to do with
um you know where the story came from
did it come from the customer that would
be considered a functional requirement
if it came from the team that would be
from the technical domain i'm trying to
write where from
uh you know it's not me team it's the
mouse
clearly
it's hard to uh
do that that's from where from um here
it's got uh customer tech you could also
have defect you could maybe have risk
and then there's also going to be an x
factor
which would be
some kind of word probably like
stable
erratic
incomplete
something like that to
so the team is designating the user
story in
respect to the amount of uncertainty or
risk that's associated with that user
story
and because all of that's a part of the
story right the story is going to be
turned into working software there may
need to be
some efforts to actually figure out how
to actually do that user story
so that's the x factor um over to the
right here on the same chart we have
some comments about
if you are using a software package
excuse me like trello or jira or
something like that excuse me
the user story cards will generally be
able to contain more information using
you know dynamic links
and things like that
could even include things like
responsible team member or depending on
how you're doing it you would break the
user story down into tasks and you might
have team members assigned to various
tasks for the user story
okay so that's typically what a user
story card is like sometimes they're
cards sometimes they're like on sticky
notes and they're put up on a kanban
board if you're using kanban to track
the project
if you have a story that is too large to
be completed in a sprint it's going to
have to be
subdivided or we call it disaggregation
into
smaller user stories and there's uh
three ways that we're proposing here
that you could go about doing that you
could split it based on operational
boundaries for example as an operator
one needs to manage reservations which
could be split for example there could
be one portion that is
that has to do with making a reservation
another one that has to do with
modifying it and yet another one that
has to do with canceling it
so um that could be split into in this
construct here three separate user
stories
you could also separate based on
exceptions or cross-cutting concerns for
example
in the beginning develop only one main
path like accept repayment for a loan
then address exceptions like what if a
person
overpays
then
come up with a user story that
recognizes that and processes a refund
and or gives the option of allocating
the
overpayment to a future payment or
something like that
and then also um
ads on other concerns like the check
access restrictions or record name of
operator so maybe
you know when you're working on
accepting payments or processing refunds
it's going to check
on
who the operator is or track that so
that if at a later time you know who was
it that gave this uh refund here well
you could look and see you know okay the
the operator's name was recorded or
maybe you put some restrictions so that
maybe not everybody um is allowed to do
a refund and so you would have levels of
users that have different privileges
okay and then down at the bottom
split based on data boundaries
for an example you know as an accountant
one needs to enter balance sheet
information
which could then be split into
summary information
and separately
receivable details or you know maybe you
could have ap you know so you could have
different
portions of the overall
um
balance sheet
activities that need to be done
so enter ar enter ap
etc
make sense
so just to kind of
prompt you give you some ideas about
what to do
[Music]
in a scrum project if you have the
scenario arise where a user story is
being estimated by the team and it won't
fit into a sprint
it's too big
now when it comes to determining value
for user stories this is primarily owned
by the
product owner right
and it always comes back to money but
money
you know the value
can be looked at from different points
of view
so new revenue obviously you know
getting new customers and having them
buy stuff
well below that there's another
consideration incremental revenue
so somebody's in the process of placing
an order
maybe there are some premium features
that could be add-ons at that point in
time
or maybe added later on so you have an
existing customer who actually buys
more of or enhanced parts of the
existing thing they already purchased or
are in the process of purchasing
retained value so this is um
you know
retaining customers so that they don't
go to a competitor
and then the bottom one is operational
efficiency you know how could things be
done to speed up
the process of whatever it is
so that the cost of delivering
the product is reduced
so this then leads us to a discussion
about priorities recognizing that
there are some priority concerns that
come from both
the customer domain as well as the
technical domain
and there are some prioritization models
if we look right here there is value
based prioritization
and the hierarchy of that would be high
value
followed by high risk followed by high
value
and then low risk followed by low value
and then low risk
so you know we might have written this a
little bit differently but that's value
based prioritization and this is
primarily
the product owner with maybe some input
from the team just simply deciding um
what he or she wants done most
listening to the team say well you know
there's some you know greater risks with
this user story than that
and so you'd probably want to
uh persuade the product owner to take
care of high-risk stuff first
um because that would have
a uh oh excuse me sorry
an impact on the future things that need
to be done
there's the kai the kano model
which looks at each of the user stories
and classifies them as being mandatory
linear or exciters
and the mandatory items are those user
stories that are musts
and they'll never move beyond move the
customer or the end user beyond neutral
it's if they're not there it creates
dissatisfaction
if the the you the product owner and the
team has done a good job in identifying
what are the
mandatory or threshold items
you would see that
it just gets it to
neutral that's what's expected for the
product
linear items
user stories are those user stories that
as they are implemented progressively
throughout the project and added to the
feature set it will linear increase
customer satisfaction and it can be you
know in their absence dissatisfaction
all the way up to high implementation
creating a great deal of satisfaction
for the customer and then the third
category is exciters and delighters
and those are features or functions
those are user stories that are not
mandatory and the absence of them will
never result in satisfaction going below
neutral but by adding them
you could create excitement and delight
for the customer
these would typically be things that are
features that would be included in a
premium version of the product or maybe
add-ons that are promoted you know at
the point of sale you know if you
thought about this because it'll really
help you or whatever
so that's the canon model and then
there's uyghur's relative weighting
method
and
this is all using numbers
so
each feature is given a value for its
benefit
and its penalty given a value for
penalty meaning what's the pain if that
feature or function is not included
and then there is um
the cost side and the risk side
and then those are all calculated
together and that results in
excuse me a ranking or a hierarchy which
gives you the priority for the
user stories
um we also talked about moscow didn't we
did we talk about moscow
moscow is another prioritization model
must could
i said that differently must should
could won't moscow mscw must should
could won't
and we talked about that one
thank you for that confirmation
does it seem like a long time ago or is
it just me i know it was just last
weekend but
it's like last year
okay so now let's talk about velocity
priyanka that is exactly right
so velocity is the capacity of the team
to complete
work in a single iteration
so the team has estimated the user
stories
uh for size or ideal days
and um the sprints are going to be three
weeks weeks in duration
obviously not all user stories can be
completed in a single sprint and be done
with the project well i guess maybe i
shouldn't say obviously while i'm saying
that i'm thinking well maybe you had a
very
small short duration project so you
could but the point is is that uh it's
the team's capacity to
um complete work in a given sprint and
it is
an observation it's not a prediction
so
if we're working on sprint five
and we're working on determining what
our velocity is
then
it would be the average of the previous
four sprints
if there were any outliers you would
disregard those
and so it's an observation
if we look over to question or
box number two here velocity is used to
deal with
determining how many user stories we are
going to include in a given sprint
and also how many sprints are we going
to need to create a release or a set of
user stories
and here's an example
in box number three a team completed
five user stories
that were sized five three 8
13 and 2.
two user stories each sized five
were left half complete
what is the velocity of the team
and the answer is either going to be
31 or 36
31 is the sum of the completed user
stories
if you were 36 you were claiming half of
the two that were five
so that would be a total of ten so you
claim half of it which would be five
would take you to 36
but it's not going to be 36 because the
only thing that counts towards
progress
is working software
so even if the team had finished 9 out
of 10 story points for a user story
meaning it's almost done and then the
sprint ends that doesn't get counted
towards velocity
and you don't mess around with velocity
you can mess around with your estimating
and you can mess around with
you know what user stories are going to
be completed in a sprint but you don't
the the velocity is not variable
it is what it is based on past
performance
when it comes to levels of planning
we have what's called the planning onion
and let me walk you through this here
up at the the broadest area is the
vision level
so the vision level that's the suits
right they're the ones that have the
strategy and objectives for the company
and where it's going and so they have
that overall big vision for the
uh company
which is likely going to include
products and each product should have a
roadmap
my example of that website that i'm
working on has
three versions
which make up the product roadmap
version one is the free site version two
is the membership site and version three
is the
um
uh
the pay referral commissions uh
version of the site and
the product roadmap is then supported by
releases
so for my project i have three releases
so all of the user stories needed for
the
free version are in release one all of
the additional user stories that are
needed for
the
paid version the subscriber version
and then also for version three those
are all releases three releases
and then for each sprint
we will be pulling user stories from the
release that we're working on a release
is likely going to take multiple sprints
and
and then the sprints are populated by
the individual user stories which are
then just aggregated into tasks
and we do the
excuse me the daily scrum
is the daily level of planning and
coordination so we call that the
planning onion
we already kind of talked about the
release
and road map
concept here so let's just review this
quickly
um prioritize high level ethics and
determine goals and releases so we'll
use epics and themes in order to group
things together you know what should be
included in what's released so what are
the goals for the releases
then the first bullet point established
goals of release based on market demand
regulatory needs or customer
expectations
for each release you want to estimate
the target stories
repeat until the target stories are
assigned an iteration length
i should that's it's blending some
things here
be able to estimate velocity and then
assign stories to the sprints
so we keep estimating the user stories
and we keep organizing uh that until we
can do that we can come up with an
iteration length a sprint length and
then figure out what our velocity for
each sprint is and then
assign stories to the
the sprints
uh the the next bullet down iterate
until the user stories and release
date meets conditions of satisfaction
so that's a definition of done or
acceptance for the release and try not
to pack too much into a release backlog
so
um
just like you would not want to pack too
many user stories into a sprint you want
to have the timelines appropriate and
what are included in the
events
make sense
okay so
here's a bit more about release planning
on this slide here
you've got the product backlog here on
the left and then we might come up with
a release plan which could be flipped
and could be looked at
horizontally and you probably
plan
about
three releases in advance
or at least you're doing more of the
detailed planning on that
because things are going to emerge when
we do
you know sprint one that's going to help
in sprint two and things that happen in
sprints one and two that are going to
help
um release three
and then you've got um you know your
subsequent releases where we're just
doing very high level planning it's
called rolling wave planning where we do
detailed planning for things in the
future in canada with doing high level
planning for things in
uh the future
did i say that right detail planning for
things in the near term and tend them
with high level planning for things in
the future
and we talked about deciding as late as
possible i believe meaning that it's
better to actually plan the later
releases
for purposes of
making sure we have more information
the most information available
okay so estimation
let's start at the top left the
principles behind estimation understand
the cone of uncertainty
which is an estimate or best guess to
begin with and then progressively
becomes more accurate
in fact let's just take a break and look
at the cone of uncertainty
so at the very beginning of a project
there's going to be a high level of
uncertainty
if i were to draw this chart i would
make it a little bit more like
this
so clearly you're going to de-risk the
project
as early as you can and then eventually
all risk disappears when the project is
done
risk is uncertainty
okay below that the only estimate that
matters is the one given by the team
supported by this uh comment here
nothing is impossible for the one who
doesn't have to do it
so the product owner is like team come
on you can do this the team's like no we
know what our velocity is no the product
owner says i'm telling you
there's no way that that can't be done i
know you can do it i trust you i believe
in you
but the product owner doesn't actually
have to do the work
okay copyright overestimation and
underestimation is always going to be an
issue that we deal with
it's more likely that we will
underestimate than overestimate
and by looking at our velocity
from iteration or sprint to sprint
there could be some information that
is um
showing us that
we're underestimating for example
meaning um we're thinking we you know
the user stories are smaller than they
are and that we can get you know a
certain number done in a sprint and then
there's a fail what that would mean then
that would be discussed during the
retrospective and then we would do
something different going forward which
might include doing some re-estimating
scrum estimating is not necessarily more
difficult however scrum exposes bad
estimates sooner which is a good thing
when we were doing our um
planning poker you could see that
the first time as a team you know we
didn't know each other we didn't know
everybody's thoughts and concerns
and those kinds of things you know get
shared and absorbed as a project goes on
and so there's a higher awareness of
that
so
what we would say is that
using estimation techniques scrum
estimation techniques
might be
more inaccurate at the beginning of a
project but they will quickly become
very accurate as the
project advances forward
which is our question here can velocity
be increased over a period of time for
the project
yes it can
now it's not that it can it will
increase if the team is learning how to
work together better and better you
would expect that if i can just use my
mouse here if we were tracking
velocity
so this would be
points
completed over here
let me just do pts for points and down
here is time
and we go from sprint to sprint right
you would expect that maybe you know the
first couple of sprints the team would
be learning how to work together
and there would be a steep curve and
then it would kind of flatten out and
maybe have
you know a slow rise going forward as
the team emerges as a high performing
team they get better at their cross
functional behavior you know somebody's
shake the team just keeps chugging along
other things you know just
um
oh sorry
i bumped a thing on my screen there
um
um so the team you know learns how to
work better together and you know their
estimates become more accurate etc and
you would expect a high for a high
performing team to have a uh
a result like this for velocity where
there's quick improvement and then it
kind of stabilizes and then begins to
kick upwards
okay we talked about the cone of
uncertainty let's talk about ideal time
um
when we do estimating for user stories
we do it in ideal days when we do
estimating for tasks we do it in ideal
time which means hours i think that's on
the whiteboard or it was on the
whiteboard oh it was on it
um so
ideal time
is the amount of time it takes to
complete a piece of work
but that's based on the notion that
the team member or members are available
to do just the work
with
no distractions or anything at all so
assuming that
um priyanka could sit down
at a keyboard and code
for eight hours without taking a break
for lunch no phone calls no discussions
no meetings of any kind just work eight
hours how much could be done in that
eight hours by priyanka
that's what ideal time is
but the thing of it is is that there is
no such thing as somebody being able to
spend every minute of every day
only doing work there will be
distractions
so it has to be
converted into elapsed time now we don't
convert it to elapsed time at the user
story level but we do convert it to
elapsed time when we are dealing at the
task level
and what that looks like is
you know for each team member you're
going to have to do it separately
because some team members have more
distractions than others some might have
other duties that pull them away
whatever the case may be
you determine how much time in a given
day
a team member is available to do work so
say it's five hours out of eight
for one maybe it's six hours out of
eight for another maybe it's four out of
eight but you figure out what it is and
then you
take the average and that average
availability is used then to convert
ideal time into elapsed time
i should have circled this box here
because we talked about this as well
and then i already mentioned this here
only considers actual work time not the
distractions so that's the concept of
ideal time
when it comes to story points it's
different than that
they are a measure of size
relative to each other
so we were doing planning poker this
morning where
we were looking at grapes versus apples
and then we were looking at oranges and
and what else do we have watermelons and
coconuts
and we weren't trying to figure out
how much time it would take to eat
grapes as opposed to how much time it
would take to eat a coconut it's clear
that it's going to take longer to eat a
coconut because there's more effort
involved so we have a sense that it's
going to take more time but comparing
the coconut to our baseline of two right
we came up with a baseline of two for
the smallest user story we compare
eating coconuts to that baseline and we
say okay you know what it's going to
take more effort to
eat the coconut than it is to eat grapes
or apples
um so you can do it like we did you can
also triangulate
um for example when we did our planning
project this morning or this morning for
me rather at the beginning
um well that's not it that is the daily
stand up
here it is
if i had said team i want you to pick a
small user story a medium user story and
a large user story
and then we would then compare other
stories to those three and so we would
kind of triangulate on it
let's say that we did
you know two was small
i'm sorry i'm saying that wrong grapes
was small apples were medium and
coconuts were large
well if we then looked at orange and we
said well you know orange is
smaller than apples but bigger than
grapes so we would know this would fit
in between grapes and apples
and so let's say you know we had apples
at five and grapes at two
then we would say an orange is probably
going to be three
and the values you know now i used
in our example the modified fibonacci
series
what we do in scrum and agile if we're
using story points we're going to use
a non-linear scale for the values so
down at the bottom
here there's the modified fibonacci
sequence the way the fibonacci sequence
works by the way
um
it's the
the value is the sum of the two on the
right so let me break this right here
because this is a modified fibonacci so
13 is five plus eight eight is three
plus five five is two plus three and
three is one plus two
if we were doing the real fibonacci
series this wouldn't be 20 it would be
13 plus 8 which would be 21.
um i i don't know why some use modified
fibonacci and others not but that's just
kind of
a common thing to do if you're doing
planning poker you give everybody seven
cards one two three five eight thirteen
and twenty
another non-linear scale is doubling one
two four eight
sixteen
you typically don't go too far to the
left with the values because um that
either means that you're being too
granular or you've got stories that are
probably too big and they need to be
disaggregated
now somebody just chatted here should
some buffer time be included in the
actual estimates
let me answer that question first by
going back to ideal time and then i'm
going to come back to story points and
answer the question
when we're estimating in ideal time
we don't add
a special amount of time that we would
call a buffer we just allow for the
distractions and the interruptions which
could look like a buffer right you're
saying you know
you know priyante if
based on your duties in the organization
and our
work day of eight hours you're typically
available to be doing your project work
five out of those eight hours
so when we are converting ideal time to
elapsed time um you know we will be
building in extra time based on
distractions and interruptions we would
not call it a buffer but that's
essentially what we're doing now when it
comes to user stories
that we're using story points
it is different
the points
are for the entire amount of the work
and why might we need to have some extra
time for a user story well it's likely
going to be driven by uncertainty there
might be other uh things that impact it
but that's the main thing
sorry team
so when the team is estimating the size
of the user story
they will be including in their
discussion and estimates any extra time
or buffer time that would be needed for
that user story to be completed
so do we
accommodate
uncertainty when we're using story
points yes we're looking at the the x
factor and if we've got an unstable user
story then we're probably going to
say you know this is going to be a
bigger user story than one that's
similar but has a
much lesser level of uncertainty
so that's the story points let's compare
the two
ideal time
uses things like hours and days which is
easier to explain outside the team
right the suits like things in days and
hours
everybody's estimate may be different
not a bad thing it's easier to do at the
beginning because we're oriented to
think about time
and it does kind of shine a light on
wasted time
story points
are harder to explain outside the team
you know the suit says well
um how long is it going to take to do
user story 301 and our answer is um well
that's a 10 user story point user story
and the suit saying what does that mean
tell me how long
it's going to take
um so the suits have to be converted to
uh
story points
now
here's the thing it's a lot easier to
get consensus when we're estimating in
story points
and once we get good at it it's going to
be much faster
we have to remember it's not comparable
across teams
so
you know 18 working together will have
its own kind of system for sizing the
stories and another team that might even
be working on the same project will have
a whole different uh scheme and so if
the velocity of one team is 25 and the
velocity of another is 50 it doesn't
mean that the team with the velocity of
50 is able to do more work than the
teams whose velocity is 25.
and we did
when we got our day going um we started
with um
a planning poker exercise and so you
know we used all of the team members so
we selected the team the product owner
was there to answer any questions
the team discussed each of the story
cards and then
decided what their vote was going to be
and then everybody voted at once if
there were outliers they were discussed
and
the reasons for that
uh those variances those outliers um
were then part of the discussion and
then we did another round of voting and
we would keep doing that until we had
our estimates converge or we reached
consensus on them
okay so advantages of planning poker
it's fun it's quick it gets the whole
team involved the the team understands
um
a little bit about all of the stories
everybody contributes his or her
expertise and the discussion during the
estimation provides clarity in the
direction approach and even a bit of
design if we were in the same room team
and we were doing a planning poker
activity like we did at the beginning of
our day
together
we would be able to you know model it a
little bit better or if we tried to
unmute everybody but you could hear the
background noise i've tried doing it it
doesn't really work but you get the idea
that if the team's discussing and things
like that you would actually get to the
point where
your estimates would converge and the
team would say okay
this user story size is you know
whatever it is
okay so we need to wrap things up for
the day so we are ending right here
and that means tomorrow when we get
together we're going to be doing slide
20. you're starting with that which is
affinity estimating
and let's see affinity estimating we go
through that we're going to talk about
tracking progress using
information radiators
and then we're going to talk about what
we do when we find variances between the
plan and the actual results and then
we'll have our quiz now let's talk about
the values of scrum now this is
different than pillars this is
values so there are five
um values for that and
this is something that i want you to
memorize i'm going to switch my cameras
here and go to the whiteboard
and we're going to add
to our list
oh wrong color
you can tell i'm a project manager
because that would bother me
so
the five
values of scrum
and
there's an acronym you can see that on
the screen right see force
okay so
five
values of scrum
and c f
o
r
c
and you kind of know my style here you
don't have to do it this way you know
whatever works for you
but have some kind of a strategy for
memorizing things it will probably serve
you well
so the um the first c
is commitment
the next one there are four
four f is focus
o
is openness
set two ends or one
i don't know openness
blame it on the marker if it's not right
r is for respect
and the last c
is
courage
and so there's your little chart right
there
and
let me just briefly go over these
none of these will be a big surprise
here
we've talked about some of them already
in one context or another
um so
the for commitment that means the commit
the team is going to commit to deliver
value to the customer
they're on board there's the buy-in all
of that's there focus the team is going
to focus on the few important things
at a time so we're going to do time
boxing uh we're not going to do things
broadly specifically
focus on a few things at a time o is
openness that's analogous to
the t transparency and the pillars
meaning we're going to be completely
open in sharing um
information about the project our own
opinions our fears our concerns etc r
stands for respect and that's kind of a
360
you we respect ourselves we respect
others we respect the
concepts that we are
using as part of scrum
and um
and you know and we respect the other
stakeholders as well 360. and the last c
stands for courage and that's the
courage to make commitments
uh even when
we're in an uncertain environment
courage to deal with
fear that comes from a failure
courage to
share disagreements openly yet
respectfully
courage to participate
in debating technical approaches
etc
okay so now let's go to the scrum
lifecycle chart and what i want to do is
i want to elaborate on this just a
little bit
and i'm going to try and use my mouse to
do some
some
additions to this
first of all
we have the product backlog the product
backlog has to be kept current and we
call that grooming grooming is adding
user stories and removing user stories
from the product backlog product backlog
is the scope of the project the product
owner owns that the team assists in
that effort related to grooming is
pruning pruning the backlog is
prioritizing and reprioritizing so the
product backlog is pruned and groomed
regularly throughout the course of the
project
now
there is a meeting that takes place
right here which is called the sprint
planning meeting can i just do p
s p here sprint planning meeting
okay that is one of the ceremonies or
events
that
um takes place in scrum
in the um the sprint planning meeting
it is a time-boxed event and it is time
boxed to two hours for each week of the
sprint
so in our example here we have a 30-day
sprint so if we have a four-week sprint
then our sprint planning meeting will be
eight hours in duration
and two things happen during the sprint
planning meeting the user stories that
are going to be included in the sprint
are selected
right they're put into the sprint
backlog
which is a subset of the product backlog
containing the user stories that are
going to be completed during the sprint
and the second thing that happens during
the sprint planning meeting is the
selected user stories are then
disaggregated into tasks
and estimated
once that's done
then the work of the sprint begins
there will be a daily scrum like we did
at the beginning of our work day
together as our team
and then at the end of the work of the
sprint there will be the sprint
review
the sprint review meeting or ceremony
is also time boxed and it is time boxed
to one hour
for each week of the sprint so for doing
a four week sprint the sprint review
meeting would be
four hours in length the primary purpose
of the review
is to showcase and demo the software and
get feedback from relevant stakeholders
and allow the product owner to say i
accept or i reject the work that has
been done
then
after that is the sprint retrospective
now this is where the team
asks and answers three questions
what went well what did not go well and
what are we going to do different going
forward
regarding the
previous sprint that was just completed
and the ones that is is just coming up
and then the uh the sprint itself will
result in
working software or value for the
customer and then of course everything
goes back and repeats for as many
sprints
as necessary to complete the scope of
the project
um let's see i see a chat here how
similar or different is the product
backlog to srs software requirement
specs document which is widely used in
projects
um it's different
and if you will hang on to that question
we're going to have a discussion later
on about user stories and that will help
you understand
the differences
and we'll get into
the user stories that come from the
customer and user stories that come from
the text domain and that will help
answer your question so you can hang on
to that
okay great thanks
okay so a little bit more detailed view
of the scrum project life cycle now
let's talk about a couple other things
here
when it comes to
a sprint
there are some things that affect the
duration of the sprint
so the team is going to have to decide
how long each of the sprints are going
to be
and things that are a factor include the
stability of the product backlog if the
product backlog is changing a great deal
then that's going to argue for shorter
durations
um because there's uh a high level of
uncertainty and so you have a greater
amount of control
on your project if you have shorter
sprints now on the other hand another
factor is the cost of iterating
every time we do a sprint there are
costs associated with
the sprint planning meeting the sprint
review
the sprint retrospective right people
show up to those meetings you gotta pay
them and
um
excuse me so there
there is an overhead cost to actually
doing sprints
the goal of the sprint is working
software at the end
the end product should be near
releasable or potentially shippable now
there might be working software that the
product owner isn't going to want to
release
maybe
because it as a standalone component of
working software for the system doesn't
create any value or any usability for
end users
and maybe you wait till the end of a
release before you release everything
but the idea is it's working software
and it could be released if um the
customer wanted to do that
um
sorry just dropped something
i see a question there i will circle
back to your question in just a sec
the sprint duration and deliverables do
not change once the team has committed
this is another one of those things that
has to be viewed as absolute when we're
doing scrum so if we say that we're
going to do a two-week sprint
and we select five user stories based on
our velocity or capacity
once that decision has been made the
duration of the sprint does not change
and we do not add or remove any user
stories
now it could be possible for the product
owner to cancel a sprint but that would
be extreme
that would be because there is
such a major change to the product
backlog that the work of the current
sprint is going to be completely
irrelevant you don't change the sprint
you cancel the sprint and then the
bottom one here the sprint begins with
planning and ends with review and a
retrospective and there was a question
here are there any issues with combining
the retrospective and the planning
ceremonies and the answer to that is yes
now
could they be combined depending on the
environment the answer is yes and the
way we would arrive at whether or not it
would make sense is who's going to be
participating
but they would be separate
agendas so the agenda for the
retrospective
is what went well what did not go well
what are we going to do different and
the mandatory participants for that
meeting are the
the team the scrum team
is the
scrum master going to be there likely as
a facilitator um is the product owner
going to be there maybe maybe not if the
product owner is there you know the
product owner could maybe answer
questions and help clarify but the
product owner does not weigh in on what
went well what did not go well and what
are we going to do differently that is
all owned by the team
in the planning meeting the product
owner has to be there and the product
owner is the main driver of that meeting
the product owner is talking about or
dealing with the priority of the user
stories the team's weighing in maybe
there's some dependencies that need to
be considered but the product owner has
to make the hard decisions with regards
to what's going to be done in the next
sprint based on the constraints from the
team like velocity
and technology and sequencing and things
like that
so um i kind of answered that from a
real world point of view yes it could be
it's not desirable on the test they are
completely separate
did i get you there
i keep my eye on the chat box make sure
i got that answered well enough for you
and let's move ahead
okay the sprint planning meeting
this is looking right down here this is
conducted at the beginning of a new
sprint it's attended by the team the
product owner and the scrum master
and there are two approaches to deciding
what's going to be included in the
sprint
it can be based on commitment and it can
also be based on velocity
and the goal here
is to get team buy-in
make sure that there is
clarity between the
team and the product owner as to what
the definition of done looks like
for the user stories that are going to
be included in the sprint
and
of course it should be realistic and
achievable and you know there can be a
little bit of of um an issue where
you've got you know a well-meaning
product owner that's driving really hard
and the team says you know we can do
these sprints and the product owners
saying no come on you got to do at least
one more i got to have this one in this
sprint
you could get a question like that and
it might be what would the scrum master
do if you had a dominant product owner
that's trying to persuade the team to do
more than the team thinks it can do
and that's where the scrum master comes
in the scrum master plays the role of
the mentor the coach and
you know assisting in the resolution of
those kinds of issues without deciding
the scrum master is not a decider the
team decides
when it comes to how and the product
owner decides when it comes to what
okay
the scrum meeting uh daily scrum we've
talked about it right the entire team
attends the meeting could the product
owner be there
yes does the product owner need to be
there no
sometimes the product owner can be uh
you know an impediment to the meeting
but would be welcome but if the product
owner started asking questions or became
the focus of questions being asked the
scrum master would have to help
facilitate a change because
that would not be effective for the
daily scrum duration 15 minutes we
talked about that and the agenda what
did i do yesterday what am i going to do
today and what are my impediments
the sprint review now who attends it's
going to be the team the product owner
the scrum master
and potentially others so
optionally others you know that we would
want to get feedback from would be end
users
operations folks pursuits
all of those would be welcome depending
on the relevance of the software that's
being demoed and being
subject to the acceptance testing and
the product owner you know giving the
thumbs up or the thumbs down when it
comes to acceptance
the duration for this we mentioned this
before it's not just a flat two hours
it's one hour per week
so if you did a four week sprint you
would plan on the review being a maximum
of four hours in duration
the agenda is to
demo the completed software get feedback
and then see where we are when it comes
to the the release plan
the retrospective who is there is
attended by the team and i would modify
this slightly and i would say this is
the the mandatory group that needs to be
there um optionally the scrum master
would be there potentially you could
have an external facilitator the role of
the scrum master would be the
facilitator
now um a good scrub master being a
facilitator in a retrospective would
have some knowledge of control charts
the five why's
um
ishikawa diagrams things like that and
although the scrum master would not be
participating in the actual use of the
tools the scrum master would be
facilitating the effective use of those
tools
when it comes to duration the rule is 45
minutes
for each week
oh that was a good four that was kind of
a lousy five
so if you had a
two week
um
sprint then you would have an hour and a
half
retrospective max
and what's the purpose there's the
agenda for the retrospective three
questions what worked well what did not
go well what are we going to do
different and it's not just a chat
session well that would be part of it
you will use tools and techniques
like some that i mentioned control
charts
ishikawa diagrams um
five why's there's a number of things
that you might use
uh
in order to surface uh
assignable causes for issues so that we
could then come up with a resolution to
those
um this is where
continuous improvement um is uh going to
happen
um you know continuous improvements the
result of other things but this is the
main thing and if you get a question
about the relevance or the necessity of
retrospectives there is no equivocation
you do a retrospective after every
sprint
if you don't do a retro um
if you don't
then
there's no improvement
um you know things just stay static
okay so we talked about the four main
ceremonies right in
a scrum project
sprint planning
you with me
daily stand up
the sprint review
and then the sprint retrospective
all considered mandatory for effectively
doing scrum
and not doing them
or one of them would be considered a
sale
okay artifacts that we use when it comes
to
scrum
we've talked about the product backlog
we talked about the sprint backlog
there's also
a release backlog
depending on the size of the project it
might be advisable to
group user stories into releases
if you have a product roadmap
your releases would line up for that
for example i've got a
a real-life project that i'm working on
and my product roadmap is um
got three versions it's a website um the
first version is free
the second version includes a membership
component and the third
version includes
a referral commission
portion to it and so
i will then
do three releases i'll have all the user
stories that were resolved in version
one all over the user stories that
really result in version two so that's
what the release backlog is and so if
you look at it in sequence the product
backlog is the overall scope of the
project the release backlog is a subset
of the product backlog and then the
sprint backlog would be a subset of the
release backlog
the product backlog might look something
like this
it's a list of user stories that are
written by the product owner and are
going to be developed by the
team members
and didn't we have we had a product
backlog for
the thing that we did this morning right
so here's another example of a product
backlog
this is more of a list
and just has the title there would be a
user story card for each of the items in
the product backlog
but the idea would be it would be
prioritized
there could be user stories that are
added or removed depending on what the
product owner wants product owner owns
the product backlog
that's a given
does the product owner create all the
user stories for the product backlog in
isolation
no absolutely not
because there are technical
considerations that the product back or
the product owner might not
even consider the product
perspective is more the customer
side the end user side
and so the product owner might not even
think of things like security or
architecture related things
and there might even be
user stories that come from the
technical domain that need to be
developed before some of the
products owners user stories
another artifact is the definition of
done the definition of done is primarily
a checklist
and this is what forms the agreement
between the product owner and the team
um as to when we consider something
completely done
and if we look down here it's um
where's my i'm looking for my cursor it
says here it's usually prepared by the
scrum master in consultation with the
team
um
that is i would modify this slightly on
the definition of done is really driven
by the team
the see the scrum master is never a
decision maker if you have a scrum
master that's saying we have to have
this in the definition of done
then that's an infringement on the
empowerment of the team i agree that the
scrum master is a part of the effort to
develop the definition of done um
but i would kind of flip that
uh the scrum master's the facilitator
it's the team that still
owns that
so
um now is the product owner involved in
this absolutely because the product
owner is involved in defining the story
and what a fully implemented story looks
like
so here's a list
a short list of what a definition of
done could look like
the story has been fully implemented or
the code completed as described
automated unit tests have been developed
with at least 80 percent code coverage
it could be more than that
this is just an example automated unit
tests and acceptance tests of the story
are passing
no severity has one or two defects
and then high priority test cases have
been automated and added to the
regression suite
the definition of done we point out is
likely to evolve as the team's maturity
increases as the project advances
there are three distinct roles in scrum
the scrum master the product owner and
the development team the scrum master
assists both the development team and
the product owner the scrum master works
with the product owner to maximize
return on investment
the scrum master empowers the
development team by fostering creativity
removing impediments and coaching and
mentoring as appropriate
the product owner is responsible for
project success by defining the project
vision requirements and priorities
the product owner has to resist the
temptation to manage the team or add
more important work after a sprint has
begun
the product owner has to be willing to
make the hard choices during sprint
planning
the development team is comprised of
five to nine members with a mix of roles
and has the autonomy to self-organize
and choose how best to meet the goals of
the product owner
and is responsible for the same
a scrum master is a skilled servant
leader a scrum master has very little
formal authority however he or she is
expected to assist the team achieve the
intended outcomes without interfering
with the team's autonomy
the scrum master facilitates the scrum
ceremony such as sprint planning daily
stand up sprint review and sprint
retrospective
the scrum master removes obstacles or
impediments faced by the team
the scrum master is also a process coach
and mentor
the scrum master must not be a line
manager of the team the scrum master is
not to be a task master either
the scrum master is not a technical or
design authority
nor is he or she a decision maker for
the team
throughout the course of the project the
scrum master must not do anything to rob
the team of its empowerment and ability
to self-organize
let's talk about the attributes of a
scrum master scrum masters need to
exhibit responsibility even though they
are not solely accountable for the
team's output
they will consider it their
responsibility to remove anything that
impacts the team's productivity
they will try to enable the team to do
the best that it can
they are humble
they will work in the background and let
the team take all the glory
they will use we statements and seldom
use any i statements
they are able to set aside their ego and
shower all their attention on the team
they are by nature collaborative
they will encourage the team to have
conversations among each other and with
other stakeholders outside the team
they will nudge all the right people
into getting involved and work together
and trying to solve problems they are
committed to the team cause even if
being a scrum master is a part-time task
for them
they will give the highest priority to
the team's needs
hence the scrum master's work allocation
especially if they are part-time needs
to take this into consideration
they are able to influence
they are naturally good communicators
and able to convince others
to adopt different approaches
they apply various techniques to
mobilize organizational resources when
required
walk the political tightrope when
required and in general do whatever it
takes
to get the team the assistance it needs
they are knowledgeable it is clear that
as process coaches for the team scrum
masters need to be experts in the method
they may not be the technical or domain
experts however they are knowledgeable
enough to be able to have productive
conversations about the project being
done by the team tasks for the scrum
master the scrum master is a crucial
role and it is important for you to be
able to be clear about exactly how the
scrum master serves the team
scrum masters are servant leaders this
means that they put the team before
themselves and assist the team
for example they set up ensure that the
scrum ceremonies are effectively carried
out
they ensure that there is smooth flow of
information within and outside the team
and that there is a spirit of
collaboration in decision making and
problem solving
scrum masters must make it their mission
to resolve issues that hinder team
progress
it doesn't matter what the nature of the
issue is a scrum master needs to
mobilize the right resources within the
organization to resolve those issues in
a timely manner and escalate promptly if
that does not happen
we need to understand
that in the short duration of a sprint
even a few hours of being stuck
can make the difference between a
successful and unsuccessful sprint
scrum masters protect the team they
ensure that the team is not disturbed or
asked to deviate from their commitments
if pressure mounts due to unreasonable
expectations they will step in and push
back on the team's behalf
they will also play the role of
peacemaker when conflict arises by
encouraging the parties to focus on the
issue discuss the issue with an open
mind and resolve the conflict
finally scrum masters are the process
coaches of the team
they use their understanding of agile
methods and scrum in particular to guide
the team through the do's and don'ts of
scrum
they ensure that the team stays true to
the principles of agile development
scrum master roles scrum teams
before we discuss the role of a
developer on a scrum team let's talk
about the desirable characteristics of
scrum teams
they should be small and nimble
team size should be no less than three
and no more than nine so that would be
six plus or minus three
exceptions are possible but uncommon
the small attribute makes the team
nimble and improves productivity
it avoids the phenomenon mike cohn calls
social loafing
and instead produces focus on work
the team size should be just large
enough that the team members are able to
produce and showcase a significant
increment of work at the end of each
sprint
sprint after sprint
self-sufficient and cross-functional
for example if a team needs user
interface development skills
database expertise and service expertise
all of those skills must be present on
the team
ideally team members are generalizing
specialists team members should not only
be an expert or a specialist at one
aspect of the development effort
but should also have enough skills and
knowledge to fill in in other roles as
necessary for example if you are a ui
developer
you should be able to don the hat of a
services developer if needed
if a large team is to be split up into
smaller scrum teams
scrum favors feature teams over
component teams
autonomous and self-organizing
teams choose for themselves how they are
going to organize and meet the goals of
the product owner
no one gets to dictate to the team how
to get their work done
the team decides in collaboration with
the product owner the project direction
and the pros and cons of different
approaches
let's talk about some key decision
points or factors to consider when
assembling scrum teams
feature teams over component teams
the first issue is whether it's best to
align team members based on features or
components scrum favors feature teams
over component teams for example
it's best to avoid putting all of the ui
developers together and all of the api
or services developers together
why
because each feature or user story will
require both the ui
and services or api
organizing based on components will
reduce the incentive to collaborate
the only reason component teams may be
justified would be if the components are
likely to be used by multiple other
teams
assemble the right people it's important
to get the right mix of people together
for the team
the right level of technical and domain
expertise
teams will naturally have both senior
and junior level developers
this works perfectly as there will be
stuff that is more appropriate for the
junior developers and stuff that is not
also one of the risks of a small team is
that the team may miss out
on broader perspective and dissenting
views
one way to work around this is to
deliberately favor diversity in all
aspects gender ethnicity personality
traits etc
it may take some time for the team to
advance through the storming stage of
team development
and develop the trust necessary to work
effectively together but it can be done
once a team has been formed it's best to
preserve
and assign whole teams rather than
individuals to projects
it's best to avoid assigning team
members to multiple projects at the same
time
distributive team
a distributed team may be unavoidable
those based
at the same geographical location should
be co-located in the same team room
and technology processes and ground
rules should be put in place to overcome
the disadvantages of all team members
not being co-located
plotting team size and productivity will
likely result in an s-curve you can see
here that a team can actually be too
small
or too large remember the sweet spot is
six plus or minus three
think of scrum as a lightweight
framework that utilizes principles and
practices that assist teams in
delivering working software in short
cycles to the customer
enabling rapid feedback
continuous improvement and quick
response to change
it promotes delivering value as in
working software to the customer in an
incremental and iterative way
it is not a process or technique for
developing software
rather it is a framework within which
various processes techniques and
practices are employed
in scrum the iterations that deliver
working software to the customer are
called sprints
in each iteration
or sprint
results in potentially shippable
software
this slide is a graphical representation
of an agile project using scrum
starting at the left you can see that
the product owner owns the product
backlog and in collaboration with the
team develops the user stories or
requirements for the project
the product backlog is prioritized with
the higher priority items occupying the
top of the product backlog
in collaboration with the product owner
the team decides how to group the user
stories into releases based on the
product roadmap
once the release planning has been
completed the user stories are then
selected for a sprint
the duration of the sprint is going to
be two to four weeks
once the sprint backlog has been
determined the team then disaggregates
each user story into tasks
during each sprint the user stories are
developed
as the code is written it is integrated
into the system and daily scrums are
held at the end of a sprint there is a
sprint review where the working software
is demonstrated and presented to the
customer for acceptance
the team then conducts a sprint
retrospective
during the retrospective the team looks
at primarily three things
what went well what did not go well
and what should be done differently
going forward
the team's velocity is then updated as
are the information radiators which
transparently display the status and
progress of the project and then the
cycle repeats itself until the project
is complete
a sprint is an iteration in scrum
at the beginning of a project the scrum
team determines the duration of sprints
for the project
most sprints are going to be two to four
weeks in duration
factors affecting sprint duration
include the stability of the product
backlog
once a sprint has begun the duration is
never changed nor are any user stories
added or removed
therefore if many changes are expected a
shorter sprint duration would be best
however if the product backlog is
relatively stable a longer sprint
duration may be appropriate
overhead
there are overhead costs associated with
each sprint for example every spin is
going to have a sprint planning meeting
a sprint review and a sprint
retrospective
if a team has been able to lower these
overhead costs
by automated testing continuous
integration etc these costs can be
absorbed more easily making shorter
sprints more desirable
however if these overhead costs remain
high the team may need to use longer
duration sprints
a team may be tempted to extend the
duration of sprints in an effort to hide
their inefficiencies
remember
agile projects favor shorter duration
sprints and it is the scrum masters
responsibility to coach and mentor the
team so it can reduce waste
irregularities and overuse and make the
sprint shorter
the goal of a sprint is to deliver
working software at the conclusion of
each sprint the team should be able to
deliver near releasable or potentially
shippable software this is not easy
especially for an existing product with
a lot of legacy features but it can be
done with the right technical practices
and mature development processes
once the sprint duration has been
determined and the user stories for the
sprint have been selected the duration
of the sprint cannot be altered nor can
any user stories be added or removed
the sprint will end at the appointed
time irrespective of whether the team
has met the sprint goals or not
this allows for effective continuous
improvement
if the team is unable to deliver the
working software as planned the team
will have to figure out why that
happened and then make changes to
improve going forward
the product owner may choose to cancel
or terminate a sprint
in specific situations
for example a significant change in
priorities or a mid-course correction
may render the current sprint backlog
invalid
given that we are only talking about a
couple of weeks of work the cancellation
of a sprint would be an extremely rare
event
a sprint will begin with a sprint
planning meeting and end with a sprint
review in retrospective
there are three backlogs used in scrum
the product backlog the release backlog
and the sprint backlog the product
backlog is the master container of all
the user stories for the project
the product backlog is continually
pruned or prioritized so that maximum
value is delivered to the customer
the release backlog is a subset of the
product backlog
releases support the product roadmap and
each release is populated with user
stories necessary for that release
the sprint backlog is a subset of the
release backlog and contains the user
stories to be developed in the sprint
as we said the product backlog contains
the user stories for the entire project
and it is the responsibility of the
product owner
user stories are features functions or
requirements that deliver value to the
customer
however the product backlog will also
have to contain technical or
non-functional user stories necessary
for the system to work properly
the product backlog may also include
risk or defect related user stories
the product owner is responsible for
keeping the product backlog current and
up to date
this is accomplished by pruning the
backlog
which is prioritizing and
re-prioritizing
the product backlog must also be
continually groomed this is the process
of adding and removing user stories
based on the needs and desires of the
customer
there are four scrum ceremonies the
sprint planning meeting
the daily scrum the sprint review
and the sprint retrospective
let's take a detailed look at each of
these ceremonies
the sprint planning meeting is time
boxed at two hours for each week of the
sprint
if the sprint is going to be two weeks
in duration then the time box will be
four hours if the sprint is going to be
four weeks in duration
then the time box for the sprint
planning meeting will be eight hours
it should be attended by the complete
scrum team including all roles
the most important aspects of this
meeting
are
the team's capacity and the definition
of done
there are two approaches to selecting
user stories for a sprint
one is based on the velocity of the team
the other is commitment driven
team buy-in is critical and the goals of
the sprint should be clearly understood
and the desired outcome should be
clearly articulated with the definition
of done
then there's the daily scrum
the time box for the daily scrum is 15
minutes regardless of the duration of
the sprint length
the entire scrum team including all
roles should attend the daily scrum
each development team member
individually answers three questions
what did i do yesterday
what am i going to do today and what are
my impediments
this is how the team members coordinate
their work and the scrum master learns
of the impediments he or she should be
taking care of
the sprint review takes place at the end
of the sprint and is time boxed at one
hour for each week of the sprint
so if the sprint were four weeks in
duration the sprint review meeting would
be four hours
it should be attended by the complete
scrum team including all roles
plus any other stakeholders who are
interested in project success
the purpose of the review is to
demonstrate working software and obtain
and assess feedback
feedback may range from full acceptance
of the completed software
to complete rejection
the sprint retrospective takes place
after the conclusion of the sprint
review and is time boxed at 45 minutes
for each week of the sprint
so if the sprint has two weeks in
duration then the retrospective would be
one and a half hours in length
it should be attended by the complete
scrum team including all roles
however the product owner's attendance
is considered optional
during the retrospective the team
answers
four questions
what worked well
what did not work well
what should be done differently
and what still puzzles us
one or several problem detection
techniques may be used in the
retrospectives and this ceremony is a
vital part of continuous improvement
at the conclusion of the retrospective
the team's velocity and the project's
information radiators are updated
then the next prince planning meeting
takes place and this cycle continues
until the project is complete the
definition of done is an important
artifact for a scrum team it is the
primary reporting mechanism for team
members and there may be a different
definition of done at various levels
definition of done for a feature or user
story
the definition of done for a sprint and
the definition of done for a release
it's really just a checklist of
activities that add verifiable and
demonstrable value to the product
it's created by the scrum master in
consultation with the team
a sample list of the items
for the definition of done criteria
is given here
the story is fully implemented or code
completed as described automated unit
tests have been developed with at least
80
code coverage automated unit tests and
acceptance tests in the story are
passing
high priority test cases have been
automated and added to the regression
suite
note this is only meant to be an example
each team's definition of done will vary
slightly depending on the maturity of
the team and the specific situation of
the team
the product team has taken up a new
project called weather master
the team is planning to move to scrum
methodology and this is an outline of
its first scrum meeting time box to 15
minutes rick is the scrum master of this
meeting where the team members discuss
what they did yesterday their plans for
today and the impediments they faced all
team members are standing up including
todd who's joined the meeting via video
chat rick holds the meeting near a scrum
board
angela the product owner is absent
rick reiterates that all discussions
would be parked until after the scrum
meeting and encourages this team to keep
the meeting short
people can chime in to resolve obstacles
hi team welcome to the daily stand-up
meeting for the product team on project
weather master
we are in sprint one and today is the
second day
as we are planning to transition to
scrum methodology i hope you will find
this daily stand-up meeting helpful
in this meeting you will provide
information about what you did yesterday
what you plan to do today
and what challenges you faced
i think everyone's here let's start i
don't see angela shouldn't she be here
i did add angela as an optional attendee
to this meeting and since she hasn't
showed up we don't have to wait for her
susan
scrum doesn't provide a specific yes or
no about the product owner's
participation in the daily scrum
the po's primary role is to provide
direction and clarify requirements and
priorities
since we don't always discuss those in
detail at this meeting the po is not
required to be here
if the pos want to attend they are
generally in listen only mode for the
duration of the meeting
they can use the information gathered
during the meeting for separate offline
conversations
[Music]
[Music]
what about todd he works from his home
office right
todd will be a part of the meeting
through video chat it is important that
we include every team member in the
meeting
hi todd how are you
i'm fine thanks am i audible
yes todd team let's all stand up for the
meeting
[Music]
[Music]
why don't you go first aaron
yesterday i was working on creating the
mock objects to mask the database calls
from the unit tests
the difficulty with this approach is
that our server side logic is so
dependent on the metadata that writing a
true mock is a mammoth exercise
there are decisions that are taken
during runtime based on the data some of
the stored procedure calls are also made
based on the values returned through
inline queries that are also embedded in
the code
i was debugging the code until about 9
pm
but for the life of me i couldn't figure
this out
aaron could we request you to be concise
when you provide an update if you think
some of the details you described might
be interesting to others why don't you
write a wiki page on it and share the
link
so getting back to your update did you
finish the task yesterday
no it turned out to be much more complex
than i had imagined i'll continue to
work on it today and see if i can figure
out an xml structure to mock the schema
and hard code some return values but i
am really stuck as far as the inline
queries are concerned
i know what you're talking about
there is a reason why the inline queries
are there in the code
this is mainly for performance reasons
when the overheads of making a procedure
call based on a metadata value and then
processing them sorry for the
interruption again guys this is a really
great conversation
may i suggest we write this issue in the
parking lot
i'm not sure what you mean by that rick
let me explain
what aaron just brought up is a blocking
issue
team members should bring these up
during the daily scrum so that everybody
knows that one of the team members is
stuck
however the daily scrum is not
necessarily the meeting where solutions
to every obstacle can or should be found
it looks like mary knows a thing or two
about the issue that aaron has brought
up
let's jot this down as a parking lot
topic
this means the team can have offline
conversations after the daily scrum to
track it down
i'm also going to make a note that will
track the impediment aaron faced daily
until it is removed you should let me
know if i can help in any way right
aaron is there anything else you would
like to say
no i am done thanks
yesterday i worked on developing the
wizards for bulk order creation i'm
almost done today i need to write code
to handle some of the exception
scenarios before i can get them over to
susan for testing that's it for me i
guess
did you forget to mention any
impediments
not really an impediment at present but
i would like to mention that my computer
probably needs to be upgraded with more
ram it has been slow for the past few
weeks
okay i wrote up some scenarios to test
the bulk order wizard i'm looking to get
my hands on the code as soon as mary is
done
today i'm also hoping to complete the
company order testing that has been
pending for a while
i'm okay for the moment but i do have
one question shouldn't we all be
updating the task board as we speak
we could it is up to you guys if you
think you want to do this during the
meeting if you ask my opinion we should
update the board as soon as we are ready
to move the tasks and not wait for the
meeting
this will ensure that the board is
always up to date and also that we use
the meeting time to focus on the
conversations
that's a great point rick i can't see
the board very well from here anyway so
maybe we should find a way to create an
electronic version of it too at some
point
great point todd why don't you go next
with your updates
all right hey rick would you like to
know about my work on the advertising
module first or the integration server
whatever the team decides is fine with
me remember this is really your meeting
and i'm only here to facilitate and
ensure we get the most out of this
meeting
[Music]
[Music]
all right then i guess i'll start with
the integration server i would like to
inform everybody that i managed to set
up the integration server that we can
use as a sandbox to test the code before
checking it in source control i'll send
everybody a link with some instructions
and credentials
i have also started looking at the
stories for the advertising module it
looks like there are a lot of open
statements in the stories that i don't
really understand i guess i should have
been paying more attention during the
sprint planning i really need to have a
conversation with angela about this that
is my main impediment right now i sent
her an email but haven't received a
response yet
i don't have anything new to add today
i'm almost through with setting up our
project on the freeware tool that i
downloaded yesterday i'll show you guys
a demo in the meeting i set up later
today
i'll try to chase down some of these
parking lot items
anything else before we close the
meeting
all right that's it for today have a
great day
do you have a moment to chat about the
inline queries real quick
the purpose of a scrum meeting is to
keep the team members updated and
resolve any impediments
it's an ideal way to kick start the day
on a positive note
the scrum master reinforces the sense of
the self-managing team facilitates
communication between team members
brings the team's focus back to what's
important and supports improvement
so before we dive into the differences
between scrum and kanban
let's have a look at what exactly scrum
is
scrum is a simple agile project
management framework that is used by
organizations to help teams collaborate
handle unpredictability and complex
projects or products while ensuring the
products delivered are of the highest
value
it describes a set of meetings tools and
roles that enable teams to work in sync
and help them structure themselves and
manage their work scrum is one of those
things that's really easy to understand
but very difficult to master
and although scrum is seen to be used
generally by software development teams
its principles and themes are pretty
universal and can be used with just
about all kinds of teamwork
with scrum teams are able to learn from
their experiences
what worked out what didn't and things
like that
they're also able to organize themselves
to handle their problems effectively and
basically improve themselves by
reflecting on them
so how does scrum work
here we have the first component the
product backlog
the product backlog consists of a list
of tasks that need to be completed so
that the goals of the stakeholders are
achieved
then the team decides what tasks from
the product backlog they want to take up
and deliver in a two to four week period
called sprint
hence the name sprint planning
next the tasks that were discussed in
the previous phase are added to the
sprint backlog
this is a set of tasks which will be
focused on in the ongoing sprint
following this the scrum team which is
usually 5 to 9 members strong will work
on these tasks
now they also have regular scrum
meetings where they talk about their
victories the issues they face and what
they plan to do in the next 24 hours
and then they have the sprint review
the sprint review is a meeting during
which the team shows what they
accomplished during the sprint
now during this time questions are asked
observations feedback and suggestions
are made
the product owner also gets feedback for
upcoming sprints from stakeholders
they also have a sprint retrospective
now during this session past mistakes
potential issues and new ways to handle
them are identified
data from here is incorporated into the
new sprint plan
the final step is increment
here a workable and usable output is
provided to the stakeholders
so now that we know how scrum works
let's have a look at kanban
kanban comes from the japanese word can
bam which literally means signboard
like scrum kanban is a popular agile
framework that is a visual system by
which the work can be managed with ease
as it progresses
kanban uses something known as the
kanban board to make these things
possible
with this you can easily identify
bottlenecks and then fix them cost
effectively at optimal speeds
the main focus with kanban is
transparency
since everything related to the tasks
are on the board
everyone can keep themselves updated
it also ensures the teams focus on their
current tasks until they're done
this limits the amount of work that's in
progress
so on the kanban board work is divided
into smaller more manageable pieces
the work that's needed to be done is
written on a note or card and placed on
a board
columns on the board help represent
where each item is
with respect to the workflow
now let's have a look at what these are
in detail
let's find out how kanban works
now the board consists of three major
components
there's the to-do list which represents
items that need to be completed
the ongoing column which represents
items that are being currently worked on
and the completed or the done column now
these represent tasks or items that have
already been completed
now although this is a physical
representation of the board
several organizations use software
versions of the board that replaces the
sticky notes with cards that can be
moved from one column to another as work
progresses
now an example of such a software is
trello
so if you want to learn more about
trello you can check out the link i'll
be adding to the live chat in a moment
at this point you guys must have
realized how similar these two
frameworks sound
so let's run through some more of their
similarities
let's find out how they are similar
firstly they both have principles of
lean and agile which means reduction of
waste and both of them are time-boxed
and iterative approaches that enable
product delivery in an incremental
manner
these frameworks aim to reduce the
amount of work in progress
this forces the teams to ensure that
they focus on a smaller set of tasks
this also makes blockers and bottlenecks
a little more visible
in both cases the work is divided into
smaller more manageable units
both of these frameworks use pull
scheduling now this means that products
are only built based on demand rather
than forecasts
transparency plays a major role in both
these frameworks by helping them drive
process improvement
and in both cases the release plan is
continuously optimized and finally both
these methods aim to deliver releasable
software often and earlier than expected
so now that we've reached midway let me
ask you guys a question
do you guys use scrum or kanban in your
workplace or do you use these software
for personal reasons
what exactly do you use these for
let me know in the live chat
now let's have a look at how these two
frameworks are different from one
another
firstly let's have a look at cadence
cadence refers to the amount of time in
a sprint or before a release
so when it comes to scrum the entire
project is divided into time constrained
iterations
that is into smaller manageable units
but when it comes to kanban it's even
driven
next criteria we're going to have a look
at
is release methodology
in scrum releases take place after each
sprint which usually takes two to four
weeks to complete
for kanban releases take place in the
form of continuous delivery
they happen in such a way that changes
like new features configuration changes
bug fixes and experiments get to the
users in a safe quick and sustainable
manner
next up let's have a look at how changes
are addressed in both these frameworks
in scrum no change can be made while
this print is in progress
once it's complete changes can be
considered in the sprint plan
and then added to the sprint backlog
with kanban changes can be made at any
time and incorporated into the workflow
now let's consider the metric that's
being measured
in scrum for planning and process
improvement velocity which is the
measure of the work that can be
completed by a team in a sprint is the
key metric
in kanban lead time is the key metric
this represents the period of time
between a new task's appearance in your
workflow and its final departure from
the system
next let's have a look at how teams work
in these frameworks
in scrum you need a cross-functional
team
to achieve your goals in a sprint
in kanban cross-functional teams are
optional but specialized themes that
focus on particular aspects of the
workflow are required
now let's talk about new additions
in scrum just like handling changes you
can't add any items between a sprint or
nitration
in kanban new items can be added to the
board as long as there is capacity
available for it
now let's have a look at the job roles
within these frameworks
scrum has three major job roles
product owner scrum master and scrum
team
with kanban you don't have any specific
job roles
now let's talk about representation
or moreover let's talk about how data
can be represented
with scrum the board needs to be reset
once a particular sprint is complete
with kanban the board stays persistent
throughout the entirety of the project
and finally let's have a look at project
link
with scrum it's better suited for longer
projects
and with kanban projects that can be
completed in a shorter period of time
are better
so which one should you choose
now selecting from these two methods is
mainly based on the requirements of the
team
do you expect your project to be shorter
do you want to make changes at any time
you don't want to set up job-specific
roles then kanban is the framework for
you
or do you want a long-running project
with different job roles and involving
cross-functional teams
scrum is the answer for you
based on the differences we discussed on
the last topic you can make an informed
decision
now let's have a look at some of the
popular companies around the world
that employ both these frameworks
some of the companies that have
successfully implemented scrum are
facebook general electronics and adobe
companies that have implemented kanban
are siemens bbc and sap
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
so as part of this tutorial we are going
to understand
the typical
interview questions which would come
across when someone faces
the interview for any of the roles in
the scrum
so question number one
what is gram
so scrum is a framework that enables
team to work together so with scrum
teams can learn from experiences
self-organize working on problems to
reflect on their victories and their
losses to improve
so this is a simple framework which will
provide
a better ability and methodology
one can able to handle it better
so scrum is very well defined
articulated and this provides a better
insights and capabilities building
excess is very easier and roles are well
defined
so define the roles in scrum so what are
the typical roles we come across in
scrum
so one of the roles we come across is
product owner
so product owner is primarily
responsible for maximizing the roi
by determining the product features
prioritizing it into a list
what needs to be focused on for the next
print and constantly reprioritizing and
refining it so what happens is whenever
we may require to deliver it is very
important for us to have the
requirements clear what requirement
needs to be fulfilled
to fulfill the requirements the products
what is produced should have specific
features and functionalities
so product owner will have the list of
features and functionalities
which needs to be created
when product comes out as a result of a
project
so product owner owns this primary
responsible to ensure these list of
features are identified and those are
prioritized as required
so next role we can think of a scrum
master
who helps teams learn and apply scrum to
obtain business value
so scrum master helps removing
impediments
impediment is anything which can stop
things to flow smoothly
so protects them from interface and
helps the team to adopt agile practices
now scrum is one of the methodologies
for agile
approaches and practices now remember
the term agile itself is not a practice
it it refers to indicate that move
faster become flexible respond to change
be flexible
now scrum methodology especially scrum
master should understand this dynamics
and ensure the team understands this and
scrum master should guide the team to
adopt these methodologies and ensure the
results are accomplished accordingly
so next role is scrum team
so scrum team is a group of individuals
who work together to deliver the
requirements of the stakeholders
so scrum team is generally of the size
like five plus or minus two
who are self-organizing so various
different capabilities the scrum team
members would have so each of their
capabilities complement
to accomplish the results required so
question number three
what are the responsibilities of this
chrome team
so scrum team is self organizing as i
mentioned earlier so it is a self
organizing team that has five to seven
members and the responsibilities would
include the development and delivery of
working products during each sprint
now we are seeing the new terminology
sprint so what is the meaning of this
print
now sprint refers to an iteration a
time-boxed iteration
which will have a specific deliverables
to be accomplished as part of it
so self-organizing team
takes that specific working piece what
needs to be delivered so that is a
sprint backlog we call it s
so from the product backlog the features
functionalities which needs to be
delivered as part of this specific
iteration called sprint time box
iteration and those sprint backlog items
are delivered
the output of the sprint would be the
features what is been taken as a working
piece working product
so to demonstrate ownership and
transparency for work assigned to them
so they own it the entire thing assigned
to them there is there should be
ownership
so ensuring the success of daily scrum
meeting by providing crisp and correct
information
so scrum has one event there are five
events basically so one of the events
which happens daily is daily scrum
meeting
where the team
comes with scrum master so they would
speak about what is that they have
accomplished
from the previous stand up to till now
is there anything which is stopping them
to move forward so giving the crisp
updates
specific summary updates so that scrum
master understands the status so any
specific
changes or any specific support which
are required scrum master would discuss
separately with those individuals and
get it done so it should be minimum 15
minutes meeting when we say daily
stand-up meeting
so scrum team collaborate with each of
the team members they work together and
they self-organize so next question the
differentiate between a jail and scrum
now it is very essential to understand
the terminology's differences
so if we just end up with looking at a
wrong understanding of each of the
terminologies then explaining will
become difficult so what does it mean by
agile and what it is when it comes to
the terminology called scrum the term
agile refers to ability to move quickly
and easily by becoming more flexible and
adaptable this is what the meaning which
gets associated with the term agile so
many times i have seen people answering
agile is a methodology edger is a
iterative and increment methodology and
also i think when you search through the
popular search engines you may come
across that which is wrong so agile is
the terminology which is used to state
to move quickly and easily by becoming
more flexible and adaptable this we
should keep in mind so if the question
may be like what are agile methodologies
then you can come across like one of the
agile methodologies scrum and you can go
on on various different methodologies
what we have
so scrum is an agile methodology
right the term scrum is the name given
to the agile methodology which enables
organization to become a child
right so to become agile obviously there
are various methodologies scrum is very
popular so that is the main difference
so further if you look at agile
manifesto on 12 principles which acts as
guidelines to become a child
so there is something called agile
manifesto
four points
clearly articulates what needs to be
focused on to become a child and that
support that is supported through the 12
principles which guides
so scrum is used in projects where
requirements are constantly changing
means i want to become agent so i adopt
scrum
so this definitely
has to align to agile manifesto and take
the guidelines whatever is mentioned in
12 principles of agile manifesto then
looking at
leadership perspective roles perspective
so manifesto mentions the required
collaboration interactions to become a
child
whereas crumb defines the roles like the
scrum master the product owner the
self-organizing teams which is
cross-functional self-organizing team
so these are the main three roles which
scrum defines now generally when we say
projects we come across the role like
project manager so do we see such
project managers in scrum answer is no
because the scrum master who engages
with team regularly
more than management they focus on doing
facilitating role to the scrum teams so
that things can be delivered the way it
is required and more flexibility is
given to the team to take the calls to
accomplish the results so scrum master
facilitates whereas the product owner as
i mentioned earlier looks at the product
backlog and prioritizes and provides
what are the features functionalities
needs to be created in the next
iterations
so speaking about flexibility
definitely agile manifesto mentions the
required focus on working software and
focusing on changes
so that that's the focus the direction
what it provides so scrum approaches
enables teams to react to changes
quickly the scrum methodology is made
such a way the team
understanding that can able to react and
those changes and modifications are made
visible to the team
so delivery perspective manifesto
provides necessary guidelines on
frequent delivery of product or software
so scrum with time-boxed iterations
called sprints
builds
delivers to the users regularly and
half-held agile principles
that is very important so delivery here
is as per the user's requirement as per
the customer requirements because
customer when we want to become a child
customer has to involve very closely
stakeholder has to collaborate without
that you cannot become a jet
so next point is about collaboration
agile manifesto stresses on individual
interactions and customer collaborations
so based on this if you look at in the
scrum how are they demonstrating this so
there are various events which happens
in scrum so as i mentioned earlier we
have daily stand-up meetings and other
scrum events like sprinters
retrospective sprint reviews
daily stand-up meetings which happens
experiment planning which happens
regularly
so it it becomes a reason for
collaboration and everyone to discuss
and take the call so question number
five
what are the main artifacts of this
chrome process now product backlog
so which consists of list of new
features
changes
which are looking organization is
looking for
to bring into the existing features
changes to the existing features bug
fixes changes to the infrastructure and
several other activities to ensure a
particular outcome so product backlog
so then we can speak about sprint
backlog a subset of product backlog
so the sprint backlog contains tasks
that the team aims to complete to
satisfy the sprint's goals so set off
product backlog things are taken put
into spin backlog
and those are the features which are
supposed to be produced as a result as
part of that particular
sprint
the team first identifies tasks from the
product backlog that need to be
delivered to achieve a goal so these
tasks are then added to the sprint
backlog
so the team first identifies tasks from
product backlog
as per the priorities
the list which is prioritized in the
product backlog that is taken put into
sprint backlog and then those are
delivered
so next you can think about product
increment the product increment is the
combination of all product backlog tasks
completed in the sprint and the value of
the increments of previous
the outcome should be in the usable
condition even if the product owner
doesn't decide to release it it is very
important each of the increments which
comes out
so needs to fulfill this
now question number six
how are the product and sprint backlog
different from one another product
backlog versus sprint backlog let us see
a few differences
so product backlog is the list of items
that needs to be completed for
developing the product
which is the list of all the features
functionality consolidated one
whereas print backlog is the list of
items to be completed during each sprint
which are taken from
product backlog
the backlog when it comes to product
backlog the backlog is collected from
the customer by product owner and
assigned to the team whereas
in sprint backlog the teams collects the
backlog from the product owner and sets
up the time frame for the sprint
so product backlog is specific to end
goal ultimate objective whereas print
backlog is spread specific to that
sprint specific iteration called sprint
in scrum
what is that we are going to produce as
part of it
product backlog is based on customer
vision whereas print backlog will vary
based on the product vision defined by
product owner so pre-orders list you
take from their product backlog
so product backlog is independent of
sprint backlog whereas
sprint backlog is dependent on product
backlog reason we know already i
explained so this is the prioritized
list of backlogs we take from product
backlog and create this uh per specific
product as part of sprint which become
sprint backdrop
so product backlog
refers to until the project is complete
the product owner maintains the product
backlog
for a sprint backlog when it comes to
sprint backlog each news prints as
backlogs added by the team
as each prints are initiated
so
next question who is the scrum master
and what does he or she do
so a scrum master promotes and supports
the adoption of scrum in the team scrum
master helps everyone to understand the
theory practices rules and values in the
scrum
so scrum master is
playing the role of facilitation
enablement
right
so scummaster ensures the team follows
chrome values principles and practices
removes blockages that may hamper the
progress of the project
protects the team from being distracted
ensuring the team delivers value during
every sprint
so next question what happens in daily
stand-up sessions so daily stand-up
sessions
are the discussion which are done daily
that takes place under usually 15
minutes
in duration
the objective is to understand what went
well
what tasks are completed from the last
stand up session
what tasks are pending and the obstacles
the team was facing
if at all any
specific task is not accomplished for
certain reasons
so what are stopping them stopping the
team to accomplish that that needs to be
made visible
so that separate meeting can be held to
discuss on that and do the necessary
corrections by taking proper actions
so the objective of this daily stand-up
meeting is to understand the overall
scope and status of the project
further individual discussion can be
taken up after the daily stand-up
sessions
as i mentioned earlier if at all if you
find something is not accomplished as
per the plan now how do we ensure that
is corrected and why is it happening is
there anything any support is required
by the team to focus on that so
something like that
can be checked on
question number nine what is scrum ban
so scrum ban is a development
methodology
that is a combination of scrum and
kanban
so this can be used to meet the needs of
the team
that aims to minimize the batching of
work and to adopt a pull based system
so kanban is called as pull based system
so which actually helps in terms of
visualizing what work is in progress
and since it is a visualized visualized
system it is visible to everyone
so
it works
in terms of making people become
conscious to take that work and get it
closed quickly
so it's also called pull system because
work is pulled from that particular list
so when this kanban
approach or methodology or thought is
applied in scrum we call it as crumb
so combination of this definitely helps
in terms of making that entire journey
successful
and supports the scrum methodology
so scrumbar includes the structure of
scrum along with the flexibility and
visualization of kanban
scrum burn is used by the teams that
need to be
structure of scrum that has the
structure of scrum and the flexibility
of a flow based method
like on1
so question number 10 what is sprint 0
and spike so the terms print 0 refers to
the short amount of effort put for
creation of vision a rough skeleton of
the product backlog so now we do this
whenever we need to understand certain
things how things looks like
to get certain insights
so this also includes insight towards
estimating the release of products so
you get some vision it gives some
clarity
right so this sprint zero are required
to create project skeleton alongside
research spikes keeping minimal design
develop a small number of stories
completely have low velocity and be
lightweight
so speaking about this spike
so spike is set off activities used in
extreme programming
i think
this was introduced there in extreme
problem programming that is one of the
agile methodologies
so involving research design
investigation making proof of concepts
etc
so the objective of spike is to reduce
the risk of technical approach by
gaining knowledge which helps
understanding requirements and to
improve reliability so more aware we are
more clarity we have i think
putting step further will become easier
so informed decisions you can take so
next question what is crumb of scrums
now scrum of scrums is a terminology
used for scaled agile techniques which
is required to control
and collaborate with multiple scrum
teams
so when will we come across the need for
collaborating between multiple scrum
teams
so these are the scenarios where
organization has a complex structure
complex in nature where you may require
to handle them
together all of them
together for accomplishing the common
objective for business
various crime teams you would have so
scrum of scrum helps in terms of better
collaboration and handle them
easily or better way better control it
is best used in the situations where
teams are working together on complex
assignments just visualizing the system
various different deliverables which are
not a simple deliverables which we can
do with the simple scrum team
instead we have
various different deliverables which
needs to be made and dynamics are too
complex
so bigger projects then scrum of scrum
approaches can be taken so scaling
the agile methodology to that level
so it is used to establish the required
transparency
collaboration
adaption adoption to the required scale
to ensure the products can be developed
and delivered so whatever the products
are delivered whatever we consider to be
delivered so those needs to
focus on the business objectives which
is very essential
so what is user story mapping
so user story mapping represents and
arranges user stories
that help with understanding the
system's functionalities the system's
backlog
planning releases and providing value to
the customers so first of all we write
user stories to understand the required
features functionality in their user
perspective
now if we map those user stories which
use a story link to other user story
which functionality links to the
functionality determining that will
become easier
so now
user story maps arranges user story
based on the priority along the
horizontal axis
on the vertical axis they are
represented based on increasing level of
sophistications
so this will help in terms of
handling in a regular flow
in a specific not regular flow specific
flow so that things can be done in order
with full clarity
so question number 13 what happens in
sprint retrospective
so after this print review
so sprint completes
so sprint review happens
the sprint retrospective is done
so during this meeting
the lessons learned what went well
what mistakes we did
what were the issues
so is there any new way of doing things
so all these are discussed
so that these necessary corrections can
be considered in the upcoming iterations
the sprints
so data from here is incorporated when
planning the new sprint so the learning
what you had you are going to collect it
what went well what went wrong what was
supposed to be the best approach and how
did we approach it is there any other
way of doing it so these are discussed
and very essential to do it at the end
of completion of each of the sprints
review question number 14
what is empirical process control in
scrum
so empiricism refers to work based on
facts experiences evidences
observations and experimentation
so empirical process control is
established and followed in scrum
ensuring project progress
and project interpretation is based on
facts of observation so actual facts and
figure is very important any decisions
what we make
any uh progression what we make should
be always based on
on ground facts and actual pictures
we should not deviate from it
so these rely on transparency
observation adoption obviously when
you're working on the data on ground
reality
so you're working on the actual one it
is transparent it is on the observed
data
the mindset of the team and the shift
required in thought process and culture
are very essential to accomplish the
agility required by organization
so mindset of the team is very essential
and adoption of process compliance to
the process the culture the behavior
obviously plays a very important role
when
you do something within the organization
so that needs to be done as per the need
which should complement to the
business objectives
very important and that should be based
on facts not on some thoughts or
assumptions or ideas
so next question is what are some
drawbacks of using scrum so scum
requires individuals who have experience
without whom the project risks
will have a risk of failure
so one does not have a capability
difficult scrum requests team to be
collaborative and committed
so
people collaborating individuals
collaborating itself is a big challenge
in many organizations so bringing this
into the place is very important when
you want to adopt scrum
so scrum requires teams to be
collaborative and committed to ensure
the required results they should work
together
and also they should collaborate with
customers stakeholders
the less experienced scrum master can
cause the failure of the project
so be careful
scrub master is the one who is
facilitator we should understand this
who enable the scrum teams who ensure
scrum teams goes the way we need them to
work
if scrum master doesn't understand this
dynamics does not have the clarity on
this obviously he or she can not enable
to team to become that
if tasks are not well defined the
project can have any inaccuracies
chrome works better for smaller projects
and would be difficult to scale to large
complex projects that's where we are
discussing on a few questions before
this
scrum of scrum we are discussing about
when it becomes a complex project which
those needs to be handled together which
will become complex
so next question is what are the skills
of a scrum master so a strong
understanding of scrum and agile concept
scrum master should have fine-tuned
organizational skills so when scrum
master is working with the
self-organizing team with various
different capabilities
so unless the organization skills
interpersonal skills if scrum master
does not have
working with them will become difficult
so if scum master should be familiar
with technology that the team uses basic
understanding of that how it works the
dynamics associated with that and scrum
master should have an ability to coach
and teach the team to follow scrum
and its methodologies
and very clear about the terminologies
artifacts
and all the events what happens
so scrum master should have an ability
to handle conflicts and resolve them
quickly
so conflict is a scenario which would
happen for various different reason
however when conflict occurs
the scrum master should not shy away
from it
own it to resolve in the interest of the
project whatever is being done it is
very important
scrum master has to be a servant leader
so it is not like i am a specific
manager or leader of certain kind and i
am doing this with certain way no i am
actually facilitating i am guiding i am
showing certain direction
to the organization so that says to the
team when i say organization speaking
about scrum team
so that they are unable to take up the
specific project and accomplish the
results accordingly
question number 17
how can
discord be dealt within the scrum team
now the root cause of the issue need to
be identified and retest
complete ownership needs to be
established when you deal with this
and try to diffuse the disagreements so
emphasizing on the focus area that
complements the project
so here when we take up any of the
discussions any of the
opportunities or any actions what we
take
everything should be revolving around
objective of ultimate objective of
whatever we are doing
so when we need to resolve something
when we get into the root causes
always it helps to
look at the actions
in terms of eliminating those causes so
once the causes are eliminated it is
quite obvious you can able to
deal with it and address it with easily
with the right set of actions
so emphasize on focus areas that
complements the project in the sense
that should be the ultimate direction
not my individual interest not that
individual interest i favor this person
i feel that person that's not to be the
case
so favoring this solution or favoring
that solution i'm okay with this
particular technology i'm very happy
with this technology not such thoughts
it is the direction what is set i should
move things in that direction so to
establish a common understanding and to
guide the team to the direction
performing continuous monitoring and
providing
complete visibility
very very important
the next question what is a user story
so user stories are an agile software
development project management tools
it provides the team with simple natural
language explanations of one or more
features written from the end user's
perspective
now for example i'm a
account holder in a bank
so first what is the facility a bank
would give to um
account holders there is atm banking
there is net banking there is mobile
banking and there is over the counter
now when bank is
working on creating certain specific
features or specific mobile app to the
account holders
now what are the things user needs that
needs to be visualized
now if i say the role here is account
holder
as a account holder i want to
download the statements
of every month
as a account holder i want to download
the statements every month this is what
my requirement is how will you
facilitate this this will provide the
insight towards
how
the bank
what are the features and
functionalities and how these
requirements are can be fulfilled by the
bank and what features functionality the
particular mobile app should have so
that
account holder can download the
statements
so user stories will provide that
insights whatever users so account
holder is not just an user here there
are many users when it comes to mobile
app of a bank
we have
people who monitor it manage it would
develop it
so they need to have a clarity on what
exactly they need and that needs to be
written
as part of user story that what features
functionality can be easily determined
out of it
so a user story does not go into detail
it just mentions as i gave an example it
just mentions how a certain type of work
will bring well into the end user
the end user in this case could be
external end users or even internal
customers or colleagues within the
organization so if i am an organization
i produce an hr application i create an
hr application
for claim processing which i don't have
till today
so that is for internal users in the
bank example and speaking about external
customers
so user stories also form the building
blocks of agile framework like epics and
initiatives
these help ensure that the team work to
the goals of the organization through
epics and initiatives so further the
requirements for making the user stories
a reality or added later
after discussing with the team so to
write user story the involvement of the
team members are very essential they
should discuss and come out and agree
yes this is the features functionality
which should be there
user stories are recorded on post-it
notes index cards or project management
software whatever is visible and
whatever is available there next
question
how are the user stories epics and tasks
different so user stories provides the
team with simple explanation of business
requirements created from the end user
perspective as we saw the few examples
in the previous questions
epics
are the collection of related user
stories they're usually large and
complex
so these epics are created with specific
objectives in mind and user stories are
grouped
so that will form an epic whereas task
refers to the one which are used to
track work
so they are used to further broken down
from the user stories so there's a
smallest unit in the scrum used to track
work a person or a team or two people
usually work on the tasks so these tasks
are these through this task i think the
features functionality what are required
to be accomplished
are done so question number 20
what is sprint now as i mentioned
earlier in the question number four
so sprint is the terminology
used in the scrum i think we explained
various different concepts as we went
through
so sprint is the terminologies used in
scrum which refers to time box
iterations so we understood what is this
iterations
in scrum approaches when we are going
through that
the creation of specific modular feature
which is part of a product is done
during the sprint
the duration of sprint varies between a
week or two so means it's a short
duration
simple few features functionalities are
taken and created so what is velocity
so velocity is a metric used in scrum
that is a measurement of
the amount of work that is completed by
team during the sprint
so this is help to measure how how
things are moving how fast they are
moving
it refers to the number of user stories
complete in single sprint
so this speaks about that speed so our
velocity velocity
uh how faster we are going how slower we
are going this helps to vary the
variations we can do that velocity
depending on what business need
so what are the responsibilities of a
product owner
so product owner define the vision of
the project
they anticipate the needs
of the customer and to create
appropriate user stories
so they don't write user stories as such
they definitely have a set of people who
should get involved the team
to write the user stories lot of
discussion has to happen brainstorming
has to happen to write user stories
but
product owner is accountable
so product owner has to evaluate the
progress of the project based on this
backlog what project a product owner has
and has to be licensed for all product
related questions the team may have
certain questions as prints as the
sprint progresses
the scrum team may have certain
questions clarification relating to the
user stories
those needs to be clarified
what is burn up and burn down charts
so generally when we say chart
it is a graphical representation so burn
up chart is a tool that is used to track
the amount of work that has been
completed
so it is a bar chart the amount of work
completed
the height of the bars keeps increasing
in burn of chart based on what is
completed
which will show the total amount of work
the need to be done for a sprint or a
project
so it is it is a bar chart where each of
the bars keeps increasing in its height
as number of things get delivered
increases
so
burn down charts typically again a
graphical representation a bar chart so
what is pending to be delivered it shows
that now initially you will have a
bigger bar and as the project progresses
the height of the bars reduces
indicating
what is that is pending for deliverables
it is a representation of how fast the
team is working through the user stories
it helps you to understand that
so it shows total effort against the
amount of work for each iterations
which is helpful for it oc to that what
is spending to
complete
question 24 how is estimation in the
scrum project done
so the estimation of user stories is
done based on its difficulty
a particular scale in which
which is used to assess the difficulty
of user stories
so to analyze
how difficult or easy is that some of
these scales which are used like numeric
sizing 1 to 10
t-shirt sizing like sml excel
fibonacci series or dog breeds based on
their
value
so many such approaches are taken
what are some risks in scrum and how are
they handled
so first of all we should know what is
risk so some types of risk in scrum are
related to the jet people
sprint
product
knowledge and capability
now when we say budget
risk of
increase
exceeding that allocated budget taking
more uh looking for more variations i
estimated for x it is going like x plus
delta x so can we control it we need to
look at that so you need to assess that
risk when what possibilities the cost
can escalate people related like team
members need to be of appropriate skills
and capabilities if they lack that
obviously
difficult it's not about just skills and
capabilities the culture the behavior
the attitude
the energy
this energy that collaboration what
people will have then sprint related in
terms of duration and deliverables
exceeding the duration
addition of scope to that sprint in
between
so that challenges
that difficulties so product referring
to user stories and epics having
ill-defined user stories and topics not
properly articulated there is no proper
visualization when you look at that user
story not understanding so nobody
nobody's explaining it correctly
so then
knowledge and capabilities so it is not
just related to the people here it's a
entire system
everyone was who is involved
with the specific resource with its
capability it can be technology
capabilities also
so when i say risk it basically involves
identification assessment analysis and
defining risk response plans and
implementing them
now
when i say assess
assessing the risks
should be qualitative as well as
quantitative
so depending on the impact and
probability of a risk if it is high
impact risk obviously we are equated to
both qualitative and quantitative
if a simple one with very less impacts
you can take the call accordingly to
what extent you may require to analyze
and have the response plans for it so
once you have implemented and defined
and implemented the response plans quite
obvious you should keep monitoring it
and manage the risks
the risk impacts and probabilities may
vary as the project progresses so we may
require to keep assessing
the identified risk and keep identifying
the new risks as you as we progress in
the project
so these are done on a continual basis
right from starting of the project till
completion the reason i told
it is essential to understand that the
impact of the risk is based on the
proximity of actual occurrence of the
risk
now for example if you start
working on something nothing is
delivered at the at the moment
now if specific risk of people people
not available
our customer is not involved initial
stage very initial stage
so
risk impact is accordingly
project would delay in entirety
or
requirements not very clear it is
delaying something of that sort of
impact you will have now as the project
progresses
almost like 50 of the project complete
now the there is some uh challenges or
risk associated with issues are
occurring related to customers
involvement
now you are made of project so again you
will have a different kind of impact 50
percent is delivered now you need to
progress because active involvement of
stakeholders including customer is very
important
when you are becoming a child
so when that is not happening as an
example i am taking the involvement of
customers the collaboration part of it
that is not happening now here the
impact level is not equal to the impact
level when when this happens in the
starting of the project same type of
risk what we are assessing
so that is the reason each of the risks
you should keep assessing
the identified one keep assessing as the
project progresses and check on is there
a new risk is introduced as the project
is progressing
so next question what are some popular
tools used in scrum
so these are the list
so you can think of github zoho trello
jira software yodex
varies of version one so now what i am
saying is
these are the tools technology tools
so when we say tools we cannot just
limit our thought to technology tools so
what exactly this tool does
what are the techniques used that we
need to be very clear right the metrics
what is measured and methodology of
measuring it and what processes are used
what steps are used
so what needs to be used
so unless we are clear relating to
specific type of project
usage of these tools may not make any
sense you cannot even implement or
customize this for the requirement what
you are trying to accomplish so you be
clear about it when you are selecting
the tool so 27 how does scrum master
tracks print progress
so we have various different events
which happens in scrum
like daily scrum meetings scrum
retrospective scrum planning
scrum review
and checking on the defects which are
escaped density of the defects
burn down
[Music]
sprint burn down
velocity
so so checking all of this
provides the better insight to scrub
master so that tracking the progress of
this print will become
easier
so how to deal with the scope creep now
before we understand the dealing with
scope tree we need to understand what is
scope creep
so the term scope creep refers to the
change which is uncontrolled and added
without checking the impact on the
constraints like scope time cost
now what happens is you will be
doing certain or delivering certain
features
now you are forced or you are influenced
or without your knowledge some
additional things are put in place
so which may impact later it may add
value it may not add value later it
doesn't matter but it may lead in terms
of
impact your cost time and
schedules
which is unexplained
and that extra effort what you have put
in extra cost what you put in
will become like
not recognized by customers and you will
not get anything paid for it so
scope
to avoid the scope creep to deal with it
one has to ensure close monitoring of
works being done on day to day basis
because scope creep can happen through
team members influencing team members
are influenced by consumer because of
that it may happen
so understanding communicating the
vision to the team for ensuring the
alignment so the team
is very sensitive about that changes
what is happening then capturing
reviewing the project requirements
regularly against what is delivered
to emphasize
to the team and customer about the
requirements signed off so that someone
will not come and
influence you or
make that additional things to be
delivered
they need not push you right ensuring
any change introduced to go through
change control so no changes
without any proper approval by the
authorities so that
only those what is required to be
implemented is implemented and that is
done formally through the formal change
request
so avoiding gold plating so it is with
different thought process when we say
gold plating
so
we were doing the projects are trying to
add certain things into the scope to
please the customer as an example
doing something additional
providing some additional features and
functionality for which we are not paid
so scro creep is not a terminology used
for it but gold plating is the term used
but however since it is an additional
scoping so we just added here
so don't say that when the moment scope
creep we says that is not gold plating
gold plating is a different direction so
just to explain you
along with scope creep what else would
happen to where the additional
deliverables would come in which is gold
plating so question 29 what is mvp and
mmp which means minimum viable product
and minimal marketing product
so now minimum viable product is a
concept of lean startup which stresses
upon the impact of learning while
performing product development so this
allows one to test and understand the
idea
by getting exposed to the initial
version of the product for target
customers and users so to accomplish
this one has to collect all the required
relevant data and learn from the
collected data so the thought behind mvp
is to produce a product to provide
access to the users and to observe how
the product is used perceived and
understood
this will also provide
more insight towards what the customers
or users needs are
so when it comes to minimal marketable
product
this refers to the description of the
product which will have a minimal number
of features that
addresses the requirements of the users
the mmp would help
also the organization reduce the time to
market because you have the clarity what
is that we may require to
provide the question number 30 what does
dod means
definition of done right
so dod refers to the collection of
deliverables
which includes written quotes comments
on coding unit tests
integration testing design documents
release notes
this would add variable and
demonstratable values to the project
development
so deword is very helpful to scrum while
identifying the deliverables to achieve
the objectives of project for the stated
reasonable
so defining the steps required to
deliver the iterations the usage of
appropriate tool like burn down to make
the process more effective
ensuring on-time feedback throughout the
project life cycle
ensuring the walkthrough of the product
backlog items are done and understood
correctly
so then creation of checklists for
product backlog item
ensuring the deword is defined to become
task oriented involving the product
owner for reviewing during this print
and sprint retrospective that is about
dvd the next question how can a scrum
master be a servant leader
it's a very important thing to
understand
so what is the meaning of the servant
leader the term servant leader mainly
stresses on service orientation which a
leader should demonstrate
so today we say every organization is
service organization
even an organization who is producing
card if there is no service orientation
they cannot sell
so more stresses on being service
orientation the scrum master needs to be
facilitator a guide a mentor etc
this helps the team have increased
involvement and empowerment so now
question number 32 how can one
coordinate between multiple teams
so one of the most common approaches for
this is kram of scrum's meeting so where
members representing each scrum team
discusses the progress
performance issues risk etc together
this is complex structure what you're
speaking about
the frequency of these meetings must be
predefined well articulated well defined
generally scrum master would represent
the particular scrum team on behalf of
that scrum team they would
go and represent the meeting represent
in the meeting
besides having a chief scrum master
who is responsible is
coordination and collaboration among all
scrums who facilitates
these meetings thank you guys with that
we have reached the end of the scrum
full course video by simply learn i hope
you have found this informative and
helpful thank you for watching stay
tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you